so in New York City there's crazy videos
going around people are jumping on cars
there's there's riding there's smashing
windows they're jumping on taxis people
are freaking out all because this guy
was promoting giving away I think it was
a PS5 now the the New York police
department has mobilized to the highest
degree they can mobilize and they're
calling it a teen takeover and it
basically is the moment this big mob
showed up they all started chanting NYPD
smyd and stuff like that and then they
started just going around smashing
things and doing whatever they want so
we're going to uh we'll uh we'll talk
about that a bit about that and we got
some other really big news ladies and
gentlemen Barack Obama is gay uh I
apparently his biographer says that he
he is I mean this is I guess it's big
news I don't know how much anybody cares
there's gonna be a bunch of people being
like oh wow I didn't I didn't know that
or something but uh I guess I guess for
whatever reason we'll uh we'll talk
about that and I don't know whatever
it's Friday so it'll be it'll be a good
time ladies and gentlemen before we get
started head over to castbrew.com buy
our coffee if you like this show you
want to support our work you go to
casper.com you buy cast Brew Coffee it
is the best coffee you'll ever have in
my opinion uh I really do think it is
the best Appalachian nights and Roberto
Jr are like some it's my favorite coffee
granted we blended it so obviously you
know I believe that because we made it
but we got a bunch of different flavors
we got the uh Blends we got sleepy Joe
decaf we got unwoke decaf we've got rise
with Roberto Jr Casper castbrew.com
become a cast Brew Coffee Club member
and you'll get three bags per month also
go to timcast.com click join us become a
member at timcast.com to support our
work directly and you'll get access to
our members only uncensored shows Monday
through Thursday at 10 p.m tonight we
will not be having one but we have those
Monday through Thursday so so do that
you can follow the show at timcast
thyroid you can follow me at timcast
smash that like button joining us to not
talk about this and so much more we got
Alx
what's up who are you I'm uh Benny
Johnson's executive producer and I'm a
Creator on x.com x.com wow
wow and and Alex Stein never left no I'm
just moving in and I'm you know here to
talk about how Gabe Barack Obama is so
but no but this is a real story no I
know it really came out uh Glenn just
Glenn Beck just uh you know talks about
it so he really doesn't feel good for
Barack to come out and be true to
himself you know what I mean it's about
time he was honest with the American
people and you know I commend him for it
we got Hannah Claire hanging out hey I'm
Hannah I'm a writer for timcast.com I
think this technically means Barack Beat
Justin Trudeau to this coming out thing
right that's the rumor maybe they're
dating yeah could you imagine that power
couple the other rumor was that he was
dating uh Emmanuel macron
something's weirder than Manuel macron
or whatever it's all weird no no no he's
dating his teacher yes macron's got
married older older lady but maybe he
needed Barack Obama on the side well
maybe true is breaking up with his wife
because she found out him and Barack
were a thing you know I'm just saying
this soap opera got so interesting and
it's like broke back Pentagon and you
know Barack Obama was like why can't I
quit you well there's always gay guys
that act straight that date like older
rich women and then go on trips with
them and stuff like that have you guys
ever seen them they're called beards yes
basically so it's like nobody knows well
we got we got I think the whole thing is
a distraction from Hunter Byron's laptop
that's all it is man keep your eye on
the prize they're like Joe Biden's like
we need a story what do we do to
distract from this and they're like
they wouldn't take the aliens we've got
to keep going yeah this one they'll
believe but Michelle is a masculine
woman she's got masculine traits she's a
beautiful woman but people there's a
conspiracy theory that she's a man you
know that was uh was it Joan Rivera said
that yeah Michael oh that's very rude
but she's definitely got a bit of she's
got she's a powerful she's got masculine
energy for a woman you know like some
men of feminine energy uh so there's
something we'll get in all that we've
got the Swiss talents here pressing
buttons yeah I'm uh pressing buttons in
for search tonight uh let's get rolling
all right here's a story from the Daily
Mail moments YouTuber Kai sanat is
arrested by NYPD for causing huge Union
Square riot with PS5 giveaway as Riders
are filmed swarming on cars twerking on
lampposts and hurling bottles there's
one video we can't show and it's got a
guy who's bleeding profusely from the
arm apparently shot himself there's
reports that a cop had his throat cut in
some way and they took his gun from him
I don't know if that's true but then you
see this video this dude bleeding a
whole lot and you're like man
something's going on now keemstar says
that he spoke with kaisanet's manager he
was not arrested as some were saying the
police are simply protecting him from
the mob and you can see here the police
are escorting him away we got a bunch of
other videos look at this one here's a
guy he's doing what looks like some kind
of Irish Dance on the top of this black
sedan well I mean it does though but
he's doing like the river dance thing I
don't know is that not that's Michael
Flatley Riverdance right there yeah he
was doing the legs back in like filming
a tick tock though but now he's now he's
jumping up and down and they're just
smashing this car up man there's a bunch
of crazy videos I don't know what photos
they got in uh on The Daily Mail but
like here's a dude and his terrible form
on that kick my friend you know he
should watch Joe Rogan do that you see
that video of Joe Rogan doing that kick
oh yeah it sounds like a gunshot when he
hits the the bag this guy should watch
more Joe Rogan uh look at this some some
guy's getting arrested who's that so
there were thousands of people that
showed up because I guess they wanted a
PlayStation and then once once they're
all there dude social order breaks down
that's it you know what I was thinking
watching this video
it's like The Purge but in slow motion
everywhere because there was that woman
in Portland she got punched in the face
and now she's a republican you've got
Walgreens getting shut down you've got
Target stores locking every product
they're the Walgreens in Chicago where
they don't have products anymore have
you seen this well I've seen where
everything's locked up no no in
Walgreens you walk into the Chicago
Walgreens there's no products at all you
walk up to a terminal and you type in
what you want and someone will carry it
out for you after you pay for it like
from like a back armored browsing
they're taking all the fun out of
shopping but you know what's funny is
Amazon tried doing that thing in Seattle
where you could walk in and take
whatever you wanted could you imagine
what it would be like if they put it in
San Francisco I mean maybe they have one
I don't know but you know Port where was
it was in Seattle yeah I was in Seattle
they put it in San Francisco Seattle's
bad enough but it's not as bad but now
they're going the other direction with
it where you walk into Walgreens there's
nothing but a counter and two terminals
you walk a terminal you type in what you
want to press enter and then after you
pay a person comes out with your bag and
says here you go well my favorite video
it went viral and I posted on my Twitter
too where it was a McDonald's in Kiev
and then a McDonald's in Los Angeles
California and the McDonald's in Los
Angeles the guys are like literally
beating up the cashiers stealing the
register and the one in Kiev in a war
zone it looked beautiful I mean it was
immaculate it couldn't have been any
cleaner so oh dude I I've I was in um my
Dan when the when what effectively
turned into the Civil War erupted and
there's actually a crazy point to make
real quick when I went to uh 2013 and 14
when I was in Ukraine they were called
protests those protests are now
historically part of the Civil War and
now the Russian war and potentially
World War III yeah but I'm in this place
where they're burning this building down
like there's just fire coming out and
you walk into McDonald's everything's
fine he's walking to the counter and
you're like yeah I'll give him McChicken
and you know I think that's nice but
McDonald's is making everyone feel
secure they're providing the stable food
yo same in Egypt when I was at the
Hilton you can look out from the 26th
floor and see time for your square and
there's like lasers everywhere people
are screaming and jumping up and down
APC is riding around right downstairs
McDonald's is a guy getting a
cheeseburger watching soccer it's The
Equalizer everyone's like we gotta
protect McDonald's like you don't riot
in the middle of a church but in the U.S
like the black lives matter protest
they'll just Loot and Destroy Everything
regardless of you know what store they
are
um so I guess they have no respect for
the sanctity of McDonald's what does
that say about us I guess well
McDonald's are better in Europe than
they are in America yeah that's true
yeah they're just and they give you
different stuff I think that's like
Chicago has a McDonald's where you can
go and order the international menu
really yeah that's where their
headquarters are yeah I think where
where is the first one is it it's not
Des Plaines is it the first McDonald's
was in California like San Bernardino
yeah but that was like deeply
controversial
dude that was hit that movie Yo he's he
was Master massively done how he stole
that from him oh yeah it's crazy
in evil book in theory he really created
a real estate company by exactly yeah so
he owned the land under him and then
took them all that's crazy and that's
still their biggest uh profit the real
estate yeah oh yeah anyway yeah we're
talking about McDonald's if you go to
Iceland I think you can get like mac and
cheese jalapeno bites at McDonald's
you've never seen all kinds one of the
best things like I've ever seen was um
you know their slogan I'm loving it yeah
it was uh Maddox you guys remember
Maddox the best page in the universe he
said I'm loving it as a contraction of
the phrase I am loving it which is an
anagram for ailing vomit I was like
that's actually pretty good he wrote
that I went to a McDonald's for the
first time in like five years in uh when
I was in Colorado Springs shooting this
music video and it was just a kiosk
there was nobody working anywhere so I
typed in what I wanted and I ordered
three double hamburgers I was just gonna
eat the meat and then they they served
they gave me the food and I left and I
checked and it was three single
hamburgers like you got one job
at this point the machine's doing it for
you how can you and I paid for double
double hamburgers but I was already gone
I didn't go back downstairs we were
talking about people destroying their
shoes were Americans being like but if
you go to Europe you gotta try the
McDonald's they've got interesting stuff
I do want to talk about this Times
Square riot because where the hell is a
National Guard Union Square Union Square
Downtown where's the National Guard how
long does it take to call someone on the
phone and be like yo get the get the big
guns in here to stop this before
buildings start getting blown up where
and this is like a is it right over or
are they still gone because this broke
pretty recently right yeah I don't know
if even like the mayor or Governor as
you can't think what do you do when a
bunch of teenagers are just there the
riot started because they were there and
they knew no one could stop them
well New York's like Lawless right now I
mean even if you do get arrested because
of the bail reform you just get out of
jail so I mean I mean it's not a safe
place to be you guys heard about uh the
new based stick man right no do you
remember the Old Bay stick man this was
the guy at the Battle for Berkeley who
had a stick and a mask and a shield and
when antifa started attacking people he
hit him with a stick now there's this uh
I think I think he's Indian or Pakistani
7-Eleven worker in California and they
were getting robbed oh yeah and then the
guy filming is like you can't do nothing
about it just let it go and then all of
a sudden I what happens is the bat like
the guy robbing him pulls out what looks
like a knife of some sort and the other
dude he puts it away but the guy grabs
him and the other guy starts beating him
with a stick like bro dude pulled out a
weapon you know what I mean and
threatened them it's like what are you
supposed to do he was also stealing he
was feeling a giant garbage cigarettes
so like that's a lot of money to lose
for a store and at what point is it like
righteous to beat someone up that's
stealing from you I mean we in Texas I
think you have the legal right to defend
yourself with Force to defend your
property with Force I typically I'm like
man it shouldn't come down to like that
guy beat him merciles like yeah I
shouldn't say mercilessly because the
guy was stealing
the dude pulled a knife yeah you pull a
weapon yeah the dude pulled the weapon
and threatened them with death now it's
like there's no longer a question of
morals it's like this this guy's
threatening to kill people like you
gotta you gotta protect yourself yeah
and I mean the guy's probably whacked
out on drugs I mean the guys you know if
you're making that decision he's
obviously well your adrenaline's going
too like it's a life or death situation
like yo look at this clip look at this
clip they're just jumping on random
people's cars
what do you do they're expressing
themselves try that in a small town yeah
yeah I love that I love that Meme
because it's the stupidest thing I've
ever heard like try that in a small town
you mean when that Ahmed Aubry guy yeah
exactly oh my gosh right those guys are
now in prison for the rest of their
lives yeah yeah try it in a small town
and then the government will come and
arrest you Nancy Pelosi suggested we get
crew served weapons for situations like
this uh especially at the capital yeah
but the thing is if this is like a flash
mob that like there was a Facebook post
and a bunch of people Facebook it's so
I'm so Gen X
um and a bunch of people showed up and
then dispersed rapidly like how do you
defend against that because it takes
time for the Army to move I feel like
this is obviously not dispersing rapidly
yes I can't tell you there's enough time
for the this much footage generated I
feel like I mean what is rapid I guess
the cops what do you do right so this
Kai sinat guy is like hey come to you
Instagram I'm gonna give you a
PlayStation and then a ride happens did
he do he didn't break the law how it
can't be a crime for you to say I'm
gonna be here and give a thing I think
they're saying an unlicensed giveaway is
something that I read that's insane yeah
to be like hello everyone like imagine
if you weren't famous and you went and
you called up like you went on Facebook
and said hey everyone I'm gonna be at
Times Square I'm gonna give you a
PlayStation 10 people show up nobody
cares but because a million people share
it and thousands show up now you're
you've committed a crime that's crazy to
me sounds like the Donald Trump thing
right yeah that's what I'm saying that's
exactly what I was going to say I mean
there is kind of some weight if you're
that big of a quote-unquote influencer
and then you influence a bunch of people
to go do something I mean I don't
necessarily think it should be liable
but I mean he has to take some
responsibility a little bit
is that alone but like he didn't tell
people to do this we did that thing
where I said hey everybody show up in DC
we're gonna skate and then like like a
couple hundred people showed up and we
skated nothing bad happened
that's not illegal no but then what if
people show up and do bad things why
would I be responsible for that simply
because I said hey I'm gonna be here
that's crazy to me is that why they
request permits because they don't want
this yeah out of control what I'm saying
is did he
organize
an event or did he just say I'm gonna be
in Times Square and I'm gonna give
someone a PlayStation like the idea that
it would be illegal for you to say
you're going to a place is insane to me
no matter who you are no matter how
famous you are yeah I mean I don't think
he told them to Riot either exactly so
yeah where's the anti-video game people
to be like see what happens when you
give out video game consoles I don't
understand like there's a whole advocacy
group here that would be saying like
this is how addicted people are to free
stuff and online like no one's
commenting on this I think part of that
is because they want to see what happens
right like that's why I feel like I
can't find a statement from um Eric
Adams the mayor of New York because he's
waiting to see what happens before he
decides where he wants to put his
message that's kind of gross you know
what's going to happen is the left is
going to claim that the enforcement
against all these people was racist oh
yeah they're gonna say they're gonna
they're gonna try and spin it in any way
possible to be like oh you know they're
a racist for you know how they did it
because when when Santa Con happens or
when football people you know go out and
it's just like St Patrick's Day they
just paid I think 13 million dollars to
a bunch of BLM writers that were
unfairly arrested did you not see that
in New York in New York yeah after the
fact yeah they just paid it out and some
of those people actually threw you know
Molotov cocktails at police cars the way
the way it works is you want to funnel
money from the government to extremists
the extremists who the government the
government goes oh gee oh no oh I guess
we should just settle yeah well speaking
of actually sued New York City the city
council I was calling and zooming into
so many meetings they would see my name
and they just wouldn't let me speak so
we sued them in federal court and they
didn't want to deal with it and they
just we just settled for 15 000 bucks
yeah they paid me uh well they have 90
days and now we're on like day 45 but
yeah they already agreed I'll get the
check and whatever you know fifteen
thousand dollars fifty I have to split
with my attorney 60 40. but uh but I'm
your wife's boyfriend and my wife's
boyfriend if you love to bring up his
cut but uh my point is when you Sue I'm
actually suing Dallas County for a
similar thing they actually fight it New
York they're like ah the cost benefit
analysis it's just cheaper to pay these
so you're saying you can sue New York
City if they're 15 000 I'll just pay you
well for your first amendment ride if
they violate your first amendment Riot
and don't let you speak well they didn't
prove they did like they did they you
didn't prove they did or didn't they
just said we don't want to bother with
it here's money yeah they didn't want to
to court and deal with it right so it
sounds like more than fifteen thousand
dollars exactly so it doesn't matter if
you're right or wrong well what I'm
saying is
where I'm suing they'll they'll actually
fight it New York they're just so over
you know inundated with lawsuits
let's talk let's talk about Donald Trump
we got this uh this tweet from Kyle
Chaney says Donald Trump swore in court
yesterday he would not attempt to
influence or intimidate Witnesses
retaliate against anyone or in any other
way attempt to obstruct the
administration of justice quote are you
prepared to comply the Magistrate Judge
asked yes Trump replied and then uh
Trump posted on Truth social I guess if
you go after me I'm coming after you and
now all these people are calling for
Trump to be locked up isn't there some
movie where it's like set a threat and
they're like no it's a promise like so
he's not threatening them maybe he's
just letting people know what his plan
is
the question I suppose is uh we asked it
last night now that we got you guys here
why didn't they not remand Trump to
custody because they wanted them to do
something like this okay can you take
this but this is now the pretext for
them to remain into custody they could
have just done it well even if you're a
president you get arrested don't you
still get secret service so maybe that's
why because it's just the logistics it's
like how are we going to put them I'm
saying if these charges were real if
they actually were concerned Trump tried
to overthrow the government they would
not let him go they'd be like bro look
at the j6ers you you you trespass on
Capitol grounds they lock you up for two
years Donald Trump is accused of making
the whole thing happen they're like ah
you're free to go buddy here's your
passport back there's your jumbo jet
have a good day plan yeah they don't
actually believe these charges well I
think that's just it and that like the
entire thing is political and I mean his
defense is going to be and his defense
for the next you know year is going to
be that it's political speech he's
campaigning this is a campaign promise
essentially uh because he could just
turn around and say I'm going to drain
the swamp or you know Purge the Deep
State type of thing well that's
campaigning so I wonder if Trump did
this on purpose hoping that they
actually use that pretext will bring him
back because then it goes to scotus and
skoda throws the whole thing out that's
that would be actually be really smart
because I mean it's First Amendment like
honestly if this goes to scotus like
everybody is saying that yeah everybody
is saying that it's oh this is thrown
out people I don't think people realize
there is no there is no path this can
take other than it gonna be wild oh yeah
yeah oh yeah because you understatement
because at the very least this has to go
to the Supreme Court a former sitting
president criminally charged there's too
many questions there's going to be
Appeals
and then how does it get handled we're
looking at the the apex of the U.S
constitutional Branch Powers each
Branch's Authority where where is that
limit how quickly do you think it'll get
to the Supreme Court though well I don't
know dershowitz said he'll get convicted
first and then it'll go to Supreme Court
but but to your point maybe this would
fast track it like if he literally you
know got remanded like I I feel like
that you know and Trump needs to be
romantic in such a way that is not
clear-cut if Trump literally goes to
Giuliani and is on camera berating him
then he's gonna have a hard time making
an argument if they try and remand it
for something like this now you've got
big questions to be asked the Supreme
Court about his right to campaign is
Free Speech correct and then they could
use that as a pretext to just throw the
whole thing out exactly yeah I think
it's going to be an uphill battle they
want to do anything they can to take
Trump out and I do think they're going
to be successful I am not trying to be
black pills or negative I just think
that Trump is going to have to
eventually and I hope this I hope I'm
wrong I think he's gonna have to
eventually either say I'm not gonna run
and then I think that that would set him
up to get a more lenient sentence I
think I mean I don't know how he gets
out of this if they're just going to
continue to just charge on this stuff
look at the polls man yeah the he's he's
beating Biden yeah yeah I know but that
doesn't mean that's only going to
encourage him to try to get him in jail
more but he could be president from jail
ugly right yeah and he fights pardon
himself and if he gets
off the ballot and then a lot of people
will just vote R and they won't even
think twice about who's on the ballot or
not so much people write them in it'll
split the vote yup and then you end up
with Newsome as president I think that's
a strong possibility have you guys heard
my theory I mentioned the past couple
days no what is it job uh Gavin Newsom
is campaigning with Joe Biden and Joe
Biden has like a heart attack or
something Gavin Newsom runs at full
speed on the stage rolls up his sleeves
and does CPR and Biden and that would be
fun screams for help and then what
happens Biden either is okay or
incapacitated Gavin Newsom then does
every press round where they're like
tell us what it was like when you ran
out to save the president's life how do
you get Gavin Newsom above Joe Biden in
the polls above Kamala Harris how do you
replace Biden with Gavin Newsom how do
you replace him without overstepping or
insulting Kamala Harris and and you know
the woke crowd Gavin Newsom saving the
life of Joe Biden well Barack Obama even
said that if you need something
up I I think that was a quote then just
have Joe Biden be in charge of it I
think the humiliation ritual is coming
up or they're going to make him step
down something's going to come up with
Hunter I don't the reason I don't think
so is because that makes the whole party
look weak and it it there's a lot of
people who vote based on party not based
on person well and just to counter that
though actually it would make them look
like hey you know he was our president
and then he did something illegal and we
held him accountable so we're actually
the party of truth because we actually
go out maybe I mean that's what they
think they could they may do that I'm
just saying that the that's there's a
net negative there because now what
they're basically saying is we we begged
you to vote for the guy who turned out
to be more corrupt and did something
illegal whereas if Biden's exit is due
to the sacrifice yeah that and and then
Gavin will say something or they'll have
like a doctor say we've been warning the
president
to take it easy but he insisted on being
there for this country and then you've
got Gavin Newsom how do you get him in
the Press rounds this is how you do it
he saves the life and then they're like
Gavin Governor Newsom tell us what
happened and then he's like he's got a
tear in his eye and he's like I looked
at this man who have I looked I've
looked up to my whole life and I said
Joe we got you you ain't going anywhere
buddy
and and and you know I knew blah blah
like it's just it just writes itself you
think Gavin news will be a good
president
you'd be the best well Kamala Harris
Let's see how did she yes no no hold on
let me answer this yes if you want to
poop in the street all right there you
go how fast a lot of people who do uh
how fast is Hunter Biden's trial moving
in comparison to Trump's right now
because it'd be interesting to see who
gets convicted first if I was Hunter if
I was like serious if I was Hunter I
would just plead guilty and get pardoned
by my dad if I wasn't him yeah you would
think he would want this to go wall
Biden is definitely for sure still
enough I don't know but look look the
the plea agreement they had was the deal
with his dad they were like I bet Joe
was like Hunter we got to get something
we're gonna do this light thing it's
gonna be a few months of probation then
it's all gone washed away we got your
back and then the judge sniffed out that
hey there's broad immunity in this
agreement that shouldn't be there it's
unprecedented and they're like uh the
prosecutors are like you're correct
that's right uh and then Hunter was like
no way no way they're gonna throw me
under the bus the whole thing's a scam
what's weird though is so if you notice
like Korean gym here anytime she's asked
about Hunter Biden at the white house uh
she says I can't comment it's a
different matter or whatever the one
answer that she gave in affirmative and
100 straightforward answer was is Joe
going to Pardon Hunter and she just said
no that's it she answered that question
she answered so that that does show that
they were probably talking about it yeah
but she doesn't agreement because she
needs a pardon him because his charges
are going to be oh yeah exactly but but
my point is she deferred every other
question except for that one so I mean
it came up and they were talking about
it behind the scenes so with with Hunter
Biden avoiding paying taxes it's like
accidental underpayment and slap on the
recharge with Trump you know having
having multiple years where different uh
accounting firms evaluate his properties
they're like this was intentional
manipulation of numbers to steal yep
it's always the worst interpretation oh
yeah well I'm all about holding our
politicians you know accountable and I
love government transparency but let's
be real a president is above the law I
mean they are a little bit Above the Law
they're they're you know they basically
you know kill people that decide to go
to war I just think that they're not a
normal person so they're setting a
precedent where they can put a
ex-president in jail it just makes our
country look bad it makes us look so bad
in my opinion it's like you know cutting
off your nose despite your face
yeah and also how the doj is under that
branch of government the executive
branch like it's like super weird how
now they are technically above the
president like asserting themselves it's
weird but I think the reality is
whichever whichever Branch the Deep
State the intelligence agencies can use
will have the most power at the time
like the idea that Congress was impeding
Donald Trump and they were going after
with those investigations when typically
the executive branch has had this
ridiculous amount of power because the
power is really with the intelligence
agencies and they just use whatever
vehicle they need to well the CIA and I
think the FBI they also say that they
are the real ones in power because the
president changes every four to eight
years and they all stay in exactly
permanent government yeah it's a deep
state it is real so what do you guys
think do you think what do you think
this goes
uh do you think that comes 2024 we all
cast our bouts and smile as we and then
when when one whichever fashion gets
elected the other faction smiles and
then waves American flags we all got in
the street and hug
yeah that's exactly what's going to
happen no I don't know I mean Kamala
Harris what if she gave a BJ to Mayor
Willie Brown together is that confirmed
though it's close enough and then she
dated Montel Williams I love that
journalism over there yeah it's close
enough can you imagine close enough well
I don't ever claim to be a real
journalist but uh they had an affair I'm
pretty sure yeah they had an affair but
you see you're being a little too
graphic here come on you gotta okay
what's an affair I mean they had to do
the hippity dibbity
they weren't just well continues she
dated Montel Williams also she dated
Montel Williams as well and she was
supposedly in a throuple she went to you
know a couple of his things and so she's
not qualified to be the president and I
think that that's kind of scaring them
is what are they going to do with
Camelot how are we going to put her you
know on the B team or how are we going
to get her yeah I think that's the
biggest obstacle for the Democratic
party right now what to do with Kamala
because I mean when Larry Elders on the
show he was saying like you will
completely isolate female black voters
which I don't know if they're enough to
tip the scales on the other hand that
goes against the cultural conversation
you've been leading for years here so
again I think that's why there was a
moment where everyone's like maybe
Michelle like maybe we can just Edge her
out but like again weird tokenism I I
don't think they know what to do I
personally think it's going to be
terminal illness route I think Joe will
announce he has a terminal illness and I
it's I mean I'm loathe to make
predictions on the internet right hello
uh because someone will wonder you know
someone will call me out on it but I I
think Trump will end up on the ballot I
can't say what's going to happen on his
legal team but I think the Republican
Party eventually will realize that like
if he continues on the way he is it
would be impossible to keep the trust of
their voters and have anyone else there
I just I don't see Trump beating Chris
Christie that's true Chris Christie's in
like Ukraine right like what is up with
all of these like Republican presidents
yeah making their visit to Ukraine like
I I don't understand I think they want
Vladimir zielinski to pass away so they
have another Franz Ferdinand so they can
start World War III could you imagine
because he's been so Joe zielinski's got
to be sweating bullets I feel like if
there's this because he's like you know
he goes to Nato and they're like here's
what we want you to do and he's like
okay but then he's got to know in the
back of his mind the NATO guys are
crossing their fingers hoping that Putin
takes him out so they can justify
expansion of War exactly right literally
like Franz Ferdinand starting World War
one I mean that's what they want they
need somebody to rally the troops and we
were joking about aliens earlier but
even Ronald Reagan said in his one of
his state of the unions the only way to
unite the worlds is if we had an
existential threat like an alien force
so I think it goes to that it's like um
they need something like him to die for
World War III to they need like that one
thing that just the straw that breaks
the camel's back we got more important
news to talk about than world war three
Alex let's jump to the story from the
Daily Caller Obama once wrote to
ex-girlfriend that he repeatedly
fantasizes about making love to men
biographer says from President Obama
once wrote that he fantasized about
having sexual relations with other men
biographer David Garrow said in an
interview published Wednesday the former
president expressed his fantasies in a
letter to a girlfriend at the time
Garrow told tablet magazine in the
interview that letter has been redacted
and is currently in possession of Emory
University according to Garrow so they
have this the ex-girlfriend provided a
copy of the letter but has redacted one
paragraph Garrow told tablet who said
she revealed the paragraph was about
homosexuality
sometime right about when Rising Star
came out Alex indirectly sold the
original sold those letters and they
ended up at Emory uh Garrow told tablet
while discussing this biography of Obama
Rising Star which touched on Obama
reportedly dreaming about homosexuality
so Emery put out a press release saying
we've gotten these rare Letters by
Barack Obama and no mention of this
paragraph that was too sensitive none of
the papers mentioned it Emery didn't
mention it so I emailed Harvey Claire
and said go to Emory archives he spent
his whole life at Emory but they won't
let him take pictures Carol said later
in the interview so Harvey has to sit
there with a pencil and copy out the
graph where Barack writes to Alex about
how he repeatedly fantasize about making
love to men Obama married his wife
former First Lady Michelle Obama in 92
Obama did not immediately respond to
daily caller's request for comment so
this is by his biographer saying that he
wrote this and I I can't imagine like I
don't know is this a thing like for a
guy to write his like private letter to
a girlfriend about wanting was Obama
trying to trick her for some reason or
is just it's just like he's admitting
this is what he's all about yeah is that
like is he trying to break up with her
by saying you know I'm actually secretly
in the guy well like maybe like that's
like maybe he wasn't really meaning it
he was just like you know you're not
right for me because uh here you go yeah
but that's so awkward and embarrassing
to say I fantasize about having gay sex
if you're not actually fantasizing about
it well I I don't don't know if it's it
could be embarrassing now that he's like
older and it was like this crude
youthful attempt at breaking up with
someone indirectly because you're too
scared to do it like a man see I feel
like it's not like breaking over I feel
like he's testing her to like see how
committed she is to him he's like okay
well I think about this and she's like
that's fine I'll stay with you no matter
what like that's really worse uh I also
I I I think they won't comment on this
but I would desperately love to see
Obama's come out and say well what's the
problem with this I mean I think we're
in the 21st you know what I mean like
because that's actually their their
easiest way out didn't Obama write that
whole uh letter about how he grew up
reading all of the books that uh like
Florida is Banning or whatever did you
say that something like I'll have to
find the tweet and I just saw uh
everybody quote tweeting it saying uh
yeah it looks like Obama just came out
as gay because all the books they're
banning are it was right before he
released his like summer reading list no
these books weren't released when Brock
was younger yeah like genderqueer and
stuff yeah and like how to buy find some
of these books are so weird and they're
all available in the public libraries
well yeah but people are just like
making the joke saying that because it
was probably some stupid statement where
they were just saying oh they're banning
books because it's literally 1984. bogus
is trying to get the beef what's next
carnivore snacks I think they should
actually ban all books just no more
books only the internet I'm big on
bisexuality right that's good you ban
all books and people are only allowed to
go on the internet but only X where Elon
Musk determines what you're allowed to
see and we have a guy's Creator because
you know I just I just don't like Mark
Zuckerberg Twitter I want Elon Musk to
be censoring me because you know you
know shout out to Barack for owning his
bisexuality and that's probably part of
why he's so charismatic if he's truly
bisexual according to this biography he
is uh or anything bisexuality the thing
is you can fantasize yeah in a way he
charismatic like um Mick Jagger David
Bowie like they were just loose or Mick
is loose like and that's part of it this
is bicep he's like not afraid of sex so
he'll like touch any anybody and that
makes them very easy to love for a man
and a woman
um so good if he was bisexual why didn't
he come out sooner right also
fantasizing doesn't make you bisexual
it's actually having sex with men would
have made him bisexual in my opinion I
don't think so I think it's more of like
a spiritual thing like if you want to do
it it makes you bisexual yeah Barack is
attracted to men he is
you know it's like it's like if you're a
dude and you're a virgin but you're
attracted to women you're not gay you're
not asexual because you've never had sex
like no you're checking to women just
like you're a virgin is it both like
because if you're straight but you have
a bunch of sex with guys
you're still straight ask him for a
friend why like you could be bi so you
it would make you gay to have sex with
men but it also makes you gay to think
about having sex with men what I'm
saying is let's say there's a guy
there's a 20 year old guy and he's never
been with a woman but he's attracted to
women he is straight it doesn't matter
if he did or didn't yeah and there could
be a guy who's only attracted to guys he
is gay whether he did whether they do
anything or not and then you're saying
there's a guy who's only slept with guys
but he's still attracted to women he
would just be bi
yeah so is Obama I guess the question is
like he's got how does he respond to
this does he say like you know we never
actually happened
he's like he just dreams every night or
something or what like if he comes out
too hard like no I'm not gay then like I
feel like the lgbtq love me they'll be
like what
not even a little bit well did you see
the lgbtq lobby is mad at Bud Light for
not doubling down yeah they've lost all
of their market share and 400 million in
sales Bud Light Lost 400 million dollars
in sales in the last quarter or
something like that and the lobby
doesn't care that's not market share
like market share is like their stock
drop no like they actually lost that
money in direct sales they're laying
people off they're shutting down
bottling plants the Distributors are
affected yeah they're they're saying
that they expect it not to recover
because it'll always have that label as
the gay beer not that anything's wrong
with that it's great but that's who
their new faces though if Obama confirms
this letter then he shaves Bud Light
wow could you be could you imagine if
he's the next spokesman for Bud Light
he's like I'm gay and this is why
because I drink Bud Light do you think
that a lot of people are gay but they
just don't admit it
or bisexual and they don't admit it
these days I don't these days I don't
think so these days I think it's the
opposite I think people who aren't gay
are claiming they are yeah I actually
agree with Tim because then I think in
New York City they just made it where
you can put X as your gender in this
past year over 200 kids is put have put
but you get benefits yeah they're doing
it yeah for whatever the cloud uh let's
be real if you want a job let's say
you're you're 18 or whatever you're
trying to get a job nobody will hire you
easiest easiest hack you just put access
your gender then when you don't get
hired you you accuse them of of you know
discrimination and then you get in the
city pays you a hundred thousand dollars
because it's a hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars for
um violating civil rights ordinances in
New York and it's 254 willful violation
so you've got this like exploit that
people are going to try and rip off
they're gonna they're gonna say but but
even beyond that you've got these
leftists who are claiming they're part
of the LGBT community because it gives
them brownie points you know like these
like 40 year old white leftists will be
like I'm actually non-binary and then
you know that way they can claim we when
they say LGBT and stuff like that yeah
someone was like being transgender these
days is like what being goth was in the
90s it was like the trendy edgy thing to
do which means that eventually it's not
right well even the term lgbtq is kind
of
um hypocritical because if you say
lesbian gay bisexual yeah the b means
there's two genders
yes yeah when are they gonna replace
that with this LG
lgp oh pansexual they already did that's
why it's like two lbtq no it's like LGBT
something like that but they'll drop the
B is what I'm saying that's my favorite
thing in Canada where they had the
banner of lgbtqia plus they had it all
and Justin Trudeau Trudeau couldn't say
it yeah go nailed it
I don't remember what he said I just
remembered one of the times something
just stumbled through it and they had to
correct him and they like he like sighed
and then said it and it was just like so
funny every every pride month that's
what I tweeted out so
you have like a way to commemorate them
yes I do
do you think there are other presidents
who were gay like we don't know sure who
was the one who never got married that
was like the rumor that he was gay
never got married I'm gonna look it up
there was one that was always single he
was never married
maybe that sounds kind of gay poking I
know Paul James sounds like wait no
lifelong bachelor yeah Buchanan wow I
don't think that he was gay I'm just
saying people make assumptions he was
the pre-civil war president a man of a
certain age who never got married I mean
it raises questions I know especially
back then too I mean yo Buchanan was
like was like second worst present we've
ever had right the concept of a
confirmed Bachelor like that was an
allusion to like we think that oh you
think about the women that threw
themselves at him like he was the
president of the United States that he
couldn't get married I'm sorry but like
where was where was the ancient uh
Bachelor show to like make this happen
Buchanan was engaged to Ann Coleman
daughter of a wealthy Pennsylvania
family but they broke up the engagement
for an undisclosed reason and then
Coleman died shortly after oh wow
okay
and he's really good looking right yeah
what he looks like Beethoven there's one
president that everyone is like no he is
the understate uh JFK no hold on I'm
going to look he definitely wasn't gay
is this attractive to you yes you can
no that's not who I was thinking of it
looks like Sam Smith yeah he does Sam
Smith when you when you Google Dave
President Buchanan is the first one that
comes this is all for real because he
was never married and I'm sorry there
are other politicians that this comes up
about too the the idea I mean it's like
a joke that I mean uh uh Yellowstone
makes this joke that like the son who
wants to run for office they're like
yeah but you have to get married because
otherwise it starts to look weird like
there's an expectation that hopefully by
a certain point of life you have this
you know partner uh and I think James
Buchanan has always been a mystery for
history you think he was like and it's
not gonna work because I'm gay and she's
like that I'm leaving you and he's like
I shouldn't have told her that what was
I thinking I mean there's no evidence as
far as I know I'm just saying the all
the biggest thing that people question
is the fact that he never got married oh
look at this even says he was never
married and was the only US president to
remain a lifelong bachelor leading some
historians and authors to question his
sexual orientation
but he died of respiratory failure in
1868 and was buried in Lancaster
Pennsylvania uh historians will question
your sexuality no matter what at this
point because they would love to weed we
gay icons into this possible
I heard that yeah that's crazy yeah it
says William Rufus King was his close uh
I think Focus just followed Alex into
the bathroom
yeah let's let's jump to this story
because we're it's Friday night we're
bouncing around
all right you know I really I kind of
don't want to do this but with Alex
Stein here I think it'll be fun America
is using recovered UFOs to make
high-tech weapons intelligence officer
turned whistleblower claims U.S
recovered ET craft and opened Pandora's
Box in bombshell BBC interview I don't
believe it I think he's full of it uh
I'm gonna say this right now
as a statement of fact
this guy is lying about having any of
this information you know why
because he cannot prove anything he says
is true period And I would love for him
to to release hard evidence of this but
until then it's not really a statement
of fact because it's just me saying like
I don't believe him but what I'm trying
to get at is if dude were to sue me for
defamation for me calling him a liar
which he can't
show me the evidence prove it prove it
prove it
but um considering the levels of
distractions that we're dealing with we
got aliens we got world war three and we
got Obama is gay you know what I mean
it's like they're they're pulling all
the stops and Desperation Century
overload did he follow you into the
bathroom yeah he did
so uh I'm glad you're here Alexis we
want to talk about these aliens I heard
everything about the aliens I'm very
familiar with it and uh I would tell so
you've met them well I'm I am one
they're inhabiting me right now no if
they tell you that aliens are real then
they're fake if this guy that's all I
that's I believe the opposite we all
thought aliens were real until they came
down and claimed that's all they had to
do is the government tells you the
aliens are real I'm like all right this
is fake oh we're all we're all let down
well and I mean we talk about what they
have uh secret technology there is
something kind of weird that because we
can go to how did they build the
pyramids like how did they do stuff that
we can't do today there is some sort of
I think we're getting Dumber like that I
agree with but like when I say not to is
people think that because we don't know
how they did it aliens it's like come on
acoustic levitation I think that yeah
for sure like yeah they had a bunch of
horns so one of the theories is that
they would take the giant stones and
they would have like 10 guys with horns
that get really really big and they
would go Bull and then it would create
vibrations that you could just push the
block well you've seen that where like
somebody has a real big subwoofer system
in the car and just the sound of it it's
not just from the pressure they think
it's from the sound waves actually they
can bend metal I mean the car is like
bending and the metal will come back to
its uh haven't you ever seen those
little football games where it's got the
little football players on it turn it on
it vibrates and they start floating
around they're floating around like
that's that's that's that's one idea but
uh there's a bunch of stuff like that
like uh I think in in Rome they had
concrete That Could set underwater it
was like a baby yes and they I don't
think as far as I know they haven't been
able to replicate the stuff it's there
still yeah that's wild and then uh what
is it they show like um the roads in
Rome and then you see like a Road in
Dallas
you know Dallas is just potholes
everywhere but their Road in Rome is you
know still cobblestones Roman concrete
is legit it's actually something I like
just look up in my free time but it
actually gets stronger as time goes on
so it gets denser oh and what about what
about understand how they make it why
don't we just what about that uh wasn't
there like a Hellfire weapon they had
back in the day you know I'm talking
about there's like an ancient story
where these dudes are on a boat and then
they fired like Napalm or something that
Greek Fire Greek Fire yeah
I don't know what it is it was was it
green or is that that's Game of Thrones
it's green and it's a incendiary weapon
used by the Eastern Roman Empire the
byzantines developed in 672 A.D what was
it napalm
I don't know Greek fire that little
picture is pretty funny combustible
compound yeah this is how this is how
you ignited with the contacts look at
this it looks like a fan drawing maybe
magnesium if it explodes when it comes
into contact with water have you guys
seen the new John Wick there's a scene
where he gets a shotgun loaded with
dragon's breath which is magnesium
fragment shotgun shells so when you when
it shoots it class lame like not a flame
but like a big it's like metal metal
flaming metal shards
yeah yeah maybe maybe they maybe they
pulverize magnesium and then fight out
of a cannon
I want to know what it's made of uh
combinations of pine resin napatha well
alchemy's real we all agree that Alchemy
is real so I mean maybe they were able
to mix look at me well I mean what is it
what is like mixing uh no they thought
they could turn lead to Gold yeah but in
reality I think you could turn Platinum
to Gold you can turn some stuff they're
right next to each other on the Periodic
Chart it's one proton more so if you
confuse a proton with Platinum you
should turn up with gold what would you
get the proton from
hydrogen
or helium maybe you need to diffuse a
heavy hydrogen yeah if you could use
heavy hydrogen like deuterium deuterium
oxide which is like H I think there's an
added Neutron it's a water molecule with
an added Neutron I think that'd be
pretty cool we start making gold out of
plastic I think it's what's happening in
the sun is it's fusing Platinum into
gold well that's why so many people are
stealing catalytic converters because
there's a little bit of platinum in the
filter Palladium for sure there's a lot
of Palladium in the catalytic converter
I think I don't know if there's Platinum
I think there's a small amount of
platinum I think maybe this LK 99 thing
is another distraction too dude I think
it's real look at that I said I said it
was a slab yeah all of them but like for
real
all of these crazy stories drop at the
same time that Hunter Biden is about to
go to jail and Joe Biden's being caught
up in all this yeah and I'm just like
dude everything right now is a sign up
all of it I miss directions
except LK 99 no one's talking about it
in the media the mainstream crap yeah I
got the version right here I was seeing
it all over my feed for like an entire
day this week like Wednesday or
something did they MSNBC it like is
there any of that because that's all the
political uh subterfuge channels where
they're trying to get you to look away I
haven't figured it out
if we just keep talking about Hunter
Biden being crooked they'll have to keep
releasing top secrets yeah you're
milking it that's right that's right
you said that earlier today is that
people are actually trying to cause more
chaos so that the Rapture hasn't
happened sooner I kind of like that
conspiracy that's dangerous so that's
one of the one of the conspiracy
theories is that the powerful Global
Elites want to force the second coming
of Jesus so they're making prophecy
happen dear Lord yeah if I was George
Soros I would be doing that he doesn't
have much time left I mean the reason I
think LK 99 is real is because it was
developed by some Chinese dude and he
basically just showed the world but then
I don't know would the CCP allow a
Chinese guy to to tell the world about a
room temperature superconductor what
about all the people that have built the
cars that run on water have you guys
seen that yeah those are Stanley Meyer
is one of the guys here's the problem it
takes more energy to perform the
electrolysis on the water than the than
the end then the fuel produced from the
water is worth right is that true I
don't know so electrolysis splits the
the hydrogen oxygen and then you can use
the hydrogen as a fuel but the problem
is it takes more energy to perform the
electrolysis than you get back from the
hydrogen that's kind of like how they
use solar power and when
so I think a windmill has to spin every
day for five years for it to even get
back its value and what it would cost so
so you can make a car run on water but
you're just losing energy
so just have the battery directly spin
the wheel why why convert yeah water
Stanley Myers water car he said he could
run it with water instead of gasoline
but then in 1996 an Ohio court found it
to be a fraudulent claim and then the
guy was died shortly he died two years
later why why is that the final line
ever since and then the guy died shortly
later how did he who is it suicide with
two bullets in the back of the head how
did he die because I remember
hearing that and I thought it was very
weird how Stanley Meyer just abruptly
well and then there was it also saw
himself out there was like a black
security guard who died under mysterious
circumstances recently and he had a Ford
Expedition that ran on water and they
say that that he yeah
this is crazy he went to a Cracker
Barrel and I think he was there to uh
with a business meeting with his brother
two potential foreign investors and he
just got up and started vomiting ran out
and said he was poisoned and then the
the official claim is that he died from
a cerebral aneurysm wait who is it
Stanley Meyer the guy who built the
water fuel car wow Cracker Barrel's
delicious so they they would never kill
it they would never no they have the
most delicious biscuits catfish you go
to Cracker Barrel and you get the
catfish it's where you think you're safe
the chicken fried steak's good I mean
Cracker Barrel is once they got the
knickknack section yes
where people like sneak their stage
photos that they're like on a farm into
Cracker Barrel really make it a home
everyone's looking at the wef they got
the wrong idea it's been Cracker Barrel
the whole time yeah it always has always
has been always has been Cracker Barrel
if anyone in the chat knows more about
the water car please like if there's any
value to that because I mean what you're
saying makes sense that you need to
perform the electrolysis but then once
you get the chain reaction wouldn't that
that hydrogen heat give you enough
electricity to continue the reaction
I don't know if that's true I don't know
but you know what we should do because
we got the Super Chat from Michael
Beacon he gave me an idea I think we
should just get like a holla like a
projector and then do one of those
hologram things they do with like you
can Project Blue beam you can protect it
you project you put a projector on the
smoke and it can make it look 3D or onto
like a glass panel and then we just have
like aliens land in New York and then
when everyone's watching the aliens just
say like we want you all to trust your
government we have that Tim we have that
have you never heard of Project Blue
game no no no I'm saying we gotta have
aliens Line in New York and then
everyone's like what what's the message
what have what have you come to teach us
gay rights trust Joe Biden vote for him
in 2024 and everybody should be gay I
think that's what they're gonna do
future is Trends what's Project Blue
beam
so it's technology developed by NASA
this has all been Declassified where
they can actually make it look like
Jesus is coming back from the Rapture
they can make anything look like yo you
can't search for a blue beam right now
no look at this yeah I looked it up and
heavily redacted but uh no Project Blue
beam is real and it's basically whether
it's I don't know if it's hologram I
don't know how it works but they can
project an image in the sky and they say
that one of the applications would be to
fake the Resurrection talking to plasma
Ian talks about it all the time so maybe
that talking plasma is part of it where
they take triangulated lasers into a
point in the atmosphere and that creates
a ball of plasma that they'll move
around like a laser pointer if you have
if yeah you have three lasers
when they when you fire the laser you
can't see the beam you can see the point
but if all three lasers intersect you'll
be able to see a ball in the sky and
then all three lasers can move so it
makes it look like something's flying
around the speed of light and
theoretically if you've got 9000 lasers
coordinating you could create like the
image of a dragon and move that around
yeah yep that's that's not even that
complicated kids in high school do this
you ever see those uh those those shows
where the guy will be like dancing and
then he'll grab a laser beam and he'll
spin it like a like he's not really
spinning it he's just putting his hand
where the laser is and then they've
choreographed how to move to make it
look like the laser is actually in his
hands yeah but he's actually just
pretending to grab it sometimes they
mess up you can see them it's they're
cool shows but that's the kind of stuff
they can do plus didn't Tupac do a show
yeah the Hologram right if they put a
big glass thing on the stage and then
you can see a guy on the stage do this
stuff that's all of Joe Biden's second
term now weather weather right now
whether or not NASA's actually doing
anything I don't know about any of that
right that sounds like it's no I don't
know that's a conspiracy I'm just saying
we do have to technology that can
project something in the sky and be like
what is that and I mean I think that
would be beneficial if you want to
control us like I foreshadowed earlier
with Ronald Reagan that would be the way
to get us to a New World Order yeah and
then think about this Tim you don't even
think about the military industrial
complex and we could get rid of all of
our old guns and develop new alien
weapons that's just more money and then
if you think about military weapons
America that's all we produce basically
we know what they should do the U.S
should develop a directed energy weapon
but make it look really weird then claim
they got it from a spaceship they
already have directed energy no I know
but I'm saying they should make like
make one yeah and then be like look what
we found and then this is from an alien
yeah that's part of that story we just
read that they're claiming they're gonna
that they recovered alien Tech and
they're gonna then they'll make like a
beam weapon or something so we so it's
it's that the US already has like beam
weapons they uh this is really cool
video you can watch I'll try and Google
it where they have a drone flying and
then on this uh on the ship they point
an infrared laser around on it and then
it just bursts in the front
plus there's the laser induced plasma
Channel you know what that is
they can they can mount an artillery on
a truck that will shoot you with a bolt
of lightning
well they kind of have that what do they
say crowd disbursement technology sends
the same signal that a 5G Tower
theoretically could send have you ever
heard that no I don't know about that
but I'm not saying five but 5G emits a
uh frequency or whatever I don't even
know what the proper term is but that
same technology is actually used NYPD
has it where they can put it on top of a
car and it's a it'll make you feel like
you're hot like your skin is burning and
they use it oh yeah
didn't you get no with it or something
that's an active denial system and
they're it's a microwave Cannon yeah
check us out electrolyzer they call it
the way it works is there's they have
this big device
it's got two uh basically like I should
call it barrels they're not really but
there's an electrode and then there's a
laser the laser ionizes the air
superheating it in a split second so it
fires two things at once or almost
instantly the laser creates an ionized
channel of plasma which makes uh
superconductive path for electricity to
travel down
so oh wow when you when you supercharge
one of the electrodes the electricity
will just jump to the closest point
right like it wants to make the shortest
circuit so this is like a wire almost in
the sky so right so the plasma channel
is a path of least resistance so the
electricity travels down it to you and
then to the ground so they've uh there
are some videos of it and some some
videos but uh look it says it's got the
ability to incapacity or kill a living
Target through electric shock seriously
damage disable or destroying electric or
electronic devices
and uh there's really cool videos people
have made these for fun where one guy
put a bunch on his door and turned it on
and you can see straight blue lines
like a force field almost well let's go
real conspiracy I think Tesla probably
developed some sort of free energy I do
believe that I think that that's because
the government can't benefit have you
seen the was it the prestige I think
no was it the prestige
there were two movies yeah yeah and
that's with Hugh Jackman and um
who else is Hugh Jackman and who else
was in that one let's find out yeah look
it up together who is who was in that
one directed by Christopher Nolan Hugh
Jackman Christian Bale Michael Christian
Bale Christian Bale yeah they uh uh that
movie's so good I don't want to ruin it
but it's super old so I'm going to ruin
it for you yeah ruin it you've never
seen it so uh
there's two magicians that are like
competing oh I've heard about this yeah
like competing to be the best and
Christian Bale has this trick called the
transported man or whatever where he
goes in a box and then reappears on the
other side
Hugh Jackman wants to figure this one
out he's like how does he do it and he
thinks it's like he falls down and then
runs to the platform and then but it
takes too long so he tries to do this
trick where you know he falls down or
whatever as it turns out Christian
Bale's real trick was that he had a twin
brother the whole time
and so he never told anybody so nobody
knew so he was able to keep his brother
in one but Hugh Jackman goes and finds
Tesla's like secret transport device and
then actually is able to he to like do
the trick it looks like your
transporting what's really doing is
cloning and so what Hugh Jackman ends up
doing in order to do the trick and be
the best what happens is he stands on
the platform it supercharges and then
transports him to the other side of the
theater but the Hugh Jackman standing in
the platform falls into a a water tank
and drowns to death and then the huge
Eggman who gets transported to their
side carries on as the Clone the Clone
carries on and so he's like every night
I know I'm going to die
dude the movie's so good there's a
saying in the conspiracy world too that
the truth in the movie lies in the news
I know that sounds crazy but that's
where they do a lot of predictive
programming that's why there's so many
movies about like this wasn't Towers
going down before they went down wasn't
the real story that Tesla had this box
that he claimed was a death ray and not
to open it because it was too dangerous
and use it to pay his bills that was at
the end of his life and then later they
opened it it was garbage he was staying
at a hotel in New York and that was he
was like basically modern New Yorker yep
and then do you know who was called in
wait what if it wasn't garbage you're
talking about Donald Trump
the government came in and they were
like oh there's nothing but garbage in
here he was just trying to Swindle this
hotel get the death ray out of here you
know what I mean well I mean the time
machine Baron Trump
the guy that was no Steve Bannon is
Baron from the future okay that's what
it is yeah but the guy who was called in
to get his stuff and confiscate it and
investigate it was Donald Trump's uncle
Donald Trump's Uncle investigated Tesla
yeah they stumbled up on the time
machine what's his name well and then
there's a weird connection too John
Trump or something hold on well there's
a book about a person colonizing Mars
yeah yeah
what yeah yes type in the Elon
colonizing Mars Trump's uncle was John G
Trump yeah I think that's engineering
1953 book the FBI called him in yep what
is this a German uh runner Von Braun
blah blah my favorite it's called Mars
project reference a person named Elon
that would bring humans to Mars pretty
nuts yup
what are the chances and then that book
the the the the uh what's that book
called from the 1800s about Barron Trump
oh yeah it's called You're So Lockwood
or whatever I still can't believe that's
real
we got to live in the simulation yeah
like there's only something's going on
Tim I don't know what it is that
something is going on with the Elon Musk
what are the chances parents read that
book told him growing up you were named
after this character who colonized Mars
music no I think that's possible but
it's just Aaron Trump's marvelous
underground Journey now Elon came from
the future yeah
and they were like we're sending you
back a dime sometimes I think that
though because he saw like when I used
to hear him talk about it he was like
it's gonna happen anyway so we might as
well you know be prepared and use it and
I don't feel that way but I feel like if
you're from the future yeah and like
yeah no one heard of Elon Musk until
like five years ago anyway well that
didn't exist
but I just appeared out of nowhere I'm
in PayPal that's right that's the cover
story and I'm just purely speculating
this but if artificial intelligence do
you think it can communicate to itself
in the future or in the past
here's the crazy thing I think that if
we made an AI powerful an AI powerful
enough would be able to accurately
predict the future and know the past
perfectly so uh we were at this rock
store in Frederick Maryland it's a cool
place just called The Rock Shop you guys
check it out
no like actual rocks it's cool they got
all like look at these crazy Roxanne's
guy anyway they they have this fossil in
the back and it's like a perfect Cube
like it was cut from the Earth to show
like sedimentary layers or whatever
if all data was compiled like at all
information we had I'm talking like
photographs of the earth and geoscans
whatever the AI would be able to know
exactly where that rock came from
and it would be able to rewind time and
show you how it came from this piece so
there's like the simple math is a human
being looking at a jigsaw puzzle lay out
the jigsaw puzzle on the table except
one piece is not placed properly you see
the one piece and you immediately go I
know where this goes there's only one
hole that's like one plus one equals two
now remove all the pieces clutter them
up on the table and a human still very
easily I might add figures at a jigsaw
puzzle they look for the edges and they
start lining them up and clicking them
together that is like pathetically
rudimentary in terms of logical
computation an AI would be able to look
at everything on the Earth
much like jigsaw pieces jigsaw puzzle
pieces and place them together where
they were when they were why they were
how they came to be where they are and
then with enough data create predictions
of the future to varying degrees of
probability but a a a perfect AI with
perfect knowledge would be able to
perfectly predict things but have you
noticed how ai's been incorrect just
this NBA Finals there was viral tweet
like oh for sure for sure you asked Chad
gbt have the Miami Heat won the NBA
Finals before and it would say no right
because it's because it's just got
internet stuff it's like J GPT is a
predictive language model all it's doing
is looking at words we've said and then
predicting what word likely comes after
a a word right I would agree I think
that it will show us that time and space
are the same thing in that like an
artificial intelligence will show you
the the the the sequence of events are
actually places like
um their their data points so it whether
or not it happened or it was a thing
it's the same it's it's it's it both
active data so that's how the AI will
read the past it'll be like but whether
or not it can change the past I mean
what is the past except for our memory
and memory is fallible so maybe let's
check it out we can program a robotic
arm
to make perfect free throws yeah every
try and that's because the robot knows
the exact amount of energy to apply
based on the what the state of the room
is and then you you load a bunch of
basketballs and it'll fall in the arm
and then it'll launch with perfect
Precision every single time
maximize that concept to infinity and
what will you get a machine that knows
the butterfly effect perfectly that it's
like if if it wants in 10 years to have
a volcano erupt it has to drop a marble
at this point and this time drop and
then it creates a chain of events that
ultimately leads like yellow Yosemite or
you know Yellowstone or wherever the
super volcano is where is it Yosemite or
uh the geyser yeah yeah yeah the super
volcano that's in Yosemite yes
underneath it the AI will know and I
wonder because they take all the fun out
of life there's gonna be no mystery well
I mean dude they have quantum computers
already right oh yeah yeah IBM has one I
think let me double check let's take a
look like what's the current state of
quantum Computing man there's going to
be a public-facing state that we'll
learn about and there will be the actual
state which is hidden military Tech
there's a uh there's a show on FX it was
a limited series called devs devs and
it's talking about exactly this using
Quantum Computing to be able to predict
the future because they match the AI to
the Past perfectly so it now it's now
all-knowing time it doesn't you know
time's not a thing for you oh February
3rd University of Innsbruck they've
entangled two ions over 230 meters you
know what you can do with entanglement
if you were to entangle two pieces of
matter let's just say it was like a
proton or whatever I don't I'm not an
expert on any of this stuff but the
general concept would be if a proton is
entangled with another one you could
send one off to Mars okay and have
instant communication because when
they're entangled they react the exact
same way so you'd be able to transmit
data
so this is like Subspace Star Trek level
Communications where you can speak
instantly no matter where anyone is in
the universe I wonder so long as you
have these devices entangle well I know
you can entangle photons I don't know if
you can entangle atoms are you guys
aware do you know if you can entangle
protons if you split the atom that's a
nuclear bomb that's what I'm wondering
if you can entangle two protons and then
split one of them does it split the
other one too hmm or it'd be like you
that's remote detonation it'd be like a
form of but you could also remote
electrical power and stuff well it just
as any it has a group of particles for
entanglementing wild but I think they're
going to use a super computer to just
make more realistic artificial
intelligence porn I mean
we're talking about space travel and
Communications it's like we all know
what what's really going on yeah they're
gonna make more I mean Tim we're gonna
make porn we joke around but the reason
why you're streaming and basically the
reason why an independent person can
create their own podcast Studios because
in the porn cam era they were the
Forefront of creating technology where
you could live stream yourself because
people were motivated to see live people
naked I I only half agree I think a lot
of the motivation was people in the
United States wanted to watch Dragon
Ball Z but we couldn't and so the only
way to get it was to stream it because
that's how I watched it when I was
little using the Real Player you think
that they'll do I'm talking about the
fake AI girlfriend will be like if you
really want me come to me I'm on Saturn
and then that will inspire kids to
become astronauts and like develop space
travel more kids say they'd rather be a
YouTuber than an astronaut today yeah
that's what they say yeah YouTuber or an
influencer like social media jobs are
totally uh the complete focus of of uh
the youngest generation which is crazy
because this was not an option when any
of us were in high school I bet it's uh
oh sorry oh I was just gonna say I I
think uh the
I think sexiles and that's going to be
how they get a lot of people to become
okay with AI right it's going to be like
oh well it's creating this thing that
gives you all this dopamine that's it's
what what's so interesting you you see
it it's not that bad and then of course
it'll become unhinged what kind of data
are they getting from you when you log
on to these sites like I just think
there's I I don't know I'm so anti-ai I
think think there are some slight cases
where of course it could be useful but
it just seems like this Pandora's Box
that we have open and we're gonna watch
everything burn because of it dude they
will they will find a way to plug you
into the machine and yeah your brain is
not your own I know that's exactly it's
like Vanilla Sky they want you to live
in a pod I don't care you can say this
is a conspiracy but because I think
they'll use the guys of climate change
and they're going to say oh well on
Earth you live till about 70 on average
but here in the metaverse or whatever
you live to a thousand and it's going to
be indistinguishable dude there would be
a line around the block you think a line
for that iPhone is long right it would
be 10 years
You're Gonna Want What They Want You to
Want jeez so say that again
you're gonna go to the doctor and you're
gonna be like hey none of that AI stuff
for me Doc and is gonna be like okay
well you know you've got some issue with
your hair so here's a medicine to take
it you're gonna go thanks Doc I would
like to be plugged in now doctor like my
point is the moment you enter the video
game
your your brain waves are going to be
changing like they look they know how
people get addicted to alcohol and to
other drugs you think they're not going
to figure out how to make you join the
machine but you're right they're going
to want you to do it before you realize
you're doing it like with social
security numbers you know you get one
when you're born now it's not a choice
and when the first generation that
experienced Social Security numbers were
like why are you giving me this tracking
mechanism I don't want it I don't want
to be attracted I had this conversation
so much recently who's like yeah I want
to have identical twins that way I can
I'll just only register one of their
births and they can like trade off who
has a social security number when they
need it and the other one like they can
just also semi low Off the Grid because
the other people who don't have social
security numbers are like people who are
born to reclusive calls then one of the
twins could kill the other twin right
there anything could happen but it
that's a good sci-fi movie that is a
good side like the one-time I will not
share my life you know I think I think
that's basically the plot of The
Prestige kind of like the two brothers
were in secret not that they killed each
other but yeah some like twins book my
younger sisters read where it's like
there are seven girls but you're only
allowed to have like one kid so they all
like take a day of the week to go to
school or something I think this is
really funny uh but I do think that
they're I think you're totally right
like they're ultimately become a time
where you will your brain will be wired
to seek out all of these things and I
think the idea of like death and
avoiding it by getting in the Pod is
something a lot of people will be
tempted by because there's you know as
we move towards more agnostic or
atheistic culture like there's nothing
left for you afterwards so why wouldn't
you just continue to go on in the Pod
well alx's best friend and one of his
subscribers is a guy by the name of Elon
Musk and he even talks about how on a
cell phone you know our response time is
like a few milliseconds so basically
they want to install the phone in your
body so it can be instant you've seen
that it's essentially an extension of
your body at this point he talks it
already is inexcension of our body okay
with this or did you tell it on
I actually would be something I've
talked about with them but like why not
don't you care about these things I I'm
not that close to them yeah he's best
friends
what do you guys talking about I
understand he's good he's actually
leading the transhumanism push and
that's why he wants to be able to park
his Tesla with his friends yeah I would
let Elon Musk I know because he can't
because he knows we love you Elon please
don't delete my Twitter I need it I need
that or my actions
if you if your brain was connected to
your Tesla and you could drive it with
your brain if then if you went and
picked somebody up with your Tesla and
drove them around would you be driving
them or would your Tesla be driving them
and then if they decided to turn off
your Tesla would they turn off your
brain
yeah who has the right to your car if
it's connected to your brand who has the
right to my phone you all need to watch
Stargate sg1 because they have an
episode so you guys know the plot of
Stargate sg1 no Stargate can travel it's
they enter codes and it travels to
different Stargates different planets
different worlds and one of the worlds
they go to it's like they send in the
Drone and it's just destroyed it's like
Smog and apocalypse but then all of a
sudden the Drone just like blink and
then they're in this normal looking City
and there's like grass and they're like
whoa what is this I put on suits they go
there it turns out this city has this
protective sphere over it that that
protects their uh their environment from
the outside which has been totally
destroyed by pollution
one all of us like at one point in the
story one of the people they meet just
like stops and then walks blindly out to
their death just like walk straight out
through the for the force field into the
apocalypse and is gone and then when
they go around asking everybody like yo
where's Jim or whatever they're like who
and they're like that guy who is just
here like what are you talking about
there's nobody here there's only ever
been us and it turns out all their
brains are networked and the power is
running out so the force field is
shrinking and it can only accommodate so
many people so it makes you walk it
makes you it makes you kill yourself and
then forget everyone forgets you existed
and so when the force field was first
set up there was like a million people
left in the city and as the power is
slowly drained the the chip in their
minds has erased their memories to make
them fall in line and not realize what's
happening oh I hate that I really don't
know
you don't want to plug your brain into
the AI because your brain will
effectively be Wikipedia and it will be
subject to revision by popular demand
that's what the internet is not
dangerous man yeah I'm constantly
plugged in being your brain's being
Rewritten whether you realize it or not
yeah you have to discipline yourself to
take a break from the internet and put
your phone away and put any other app
that you have that is using AI away you
have to not be addicted to it well and
have you guys seen the movie Eternal
Sunshine of the Spotless Mind yeah yeah
you know because you're sad about your
ex-girlfriend you're like well why don't
I just delete her from my brain and then
they want to date again yeah and then
they get back to you
that was a rough movie yeah memory it's
so fallible yeah Vanilla Sky was creepy
too yeah Punch Drunk Love is a good one
too with uh Adam Sandler and it kind of
resonates with today with all these only
fans models how it's basically and not
trying to throw Andrew Tate under the
bus we love Andrew Tate he's the best
guy ever but um my point is you or you
think you're cyber sexing with a girl
and really you're cyber sexing with some
random dude pretending to be a girl dude
these AI women that are all over Twitter
I've been seeing all they're guys all
over Twitter they're guys like bro like
the here's here's the positive women
will no longer be able to engage in only
Fan sex work right for all the Trad
Consolidated industry and that's
probably for the best and then the bad
news for all these dudes which is it's
like you're gonna be sexting with other
dudes well I think the top three women
CEOs right now were all trans or all men
there was just I may find this to yeah
whenever they come out with these lists
of like you know top 100 women of the
world increasing well to be fair a few
years ago it was females who were
running the military military industrial
that's the craziest thing oh you know
look it comes and goes in waves you know
what I mean like some people get high
some get fired the problem I just I just
think that I'm I'm curious what Society
what porn is going to be like
like guys have to know at a certain
point like everyone's gonna know that
you're sexting another guy no it's gonna
be it's gonna be crazy because right now
when you watch the porn you know that's
the girl and but if five minutes after
it's she's still gonna be her but when
you're in the AI and you're you're
sexting or sexting with an AI woman she
can morph into like a demon in the
middle of it and then back into a like a
red block that might make it fun yo it's
gonna be they're crazy no but who's in
control of them the highest paid female
CEO is a transgender all right well I
mean good for them yeah but it's just
funny how it takes a man I mean it's
what's the name what's the name is it a
Ross Blatt uh yeah Martina rothblatt
yeah that's it it is Martin rothblatt is
the one is according to Jason burmes
Martine rothblatt is like the center of
the transhuman movement it's probably so
and I have a couple other books uh bro
there should know more about her I'm
telling you people are going to
transhuman's a thing whether you want or
not people are doing crazy stuff already
I was there was like some documentary I
think Vice was producing where these
people have gone to South America to
genetically engineer themselves to live
longer and they're doing this thing I
don't know exactly how it works but it
stops fat production and then so
something happens when your body
produces fat that causes aging so I have
no idea but I watched like a trailer for
it and they're like by shutting down
this process the body focus on muscle
development instead which will extend
your life by 20 or some odd years and
then this guy's like what do I care I'm
not going to starve to death in the
modern in the modern world so they're
injecting themselves with this this like
DNA stuff to alter their bodies
so we went we went and got stem cell
treatment for uh I got it for my hip and
it's like cured me and uh it's like a
common thing they do and it's like
fairly common on the US they they do
there's two different versions of it
there's they take your own stem cells
from your own bone marrow or they get
donor stem cells from umbilical donor
stem cells is a popular thing from
aborted fetuses not from aborted fetuses
damn no that's that's that's a bit gross
and messed up but so like for instance
uh
the I don't know how much I'm supposed
to say about the clinic we went to
because it's their business but they
they say all this stuff publicly but
there's a donated umbilical stem cells
my question is what happens is you get
stem cells they go into your body and
they see they they are attracted to
where there's inflammation when there's
cellular damage a chemical gets released
stem cells when they pass by it get
attracted to it and then become the
cells around it it repairs the damage so
whatever is like my hips totally better
I was getting the other day it was
perfect but my question to that these
guys was like I talked to another doctor
about it I said if the stem cell is
going to repair the damage well like
what if you just kept giving your self
stem cells every week
they didn't have an answer they're just
like I I don't think they told me
anything I think they're just like I
don't know because you know there's
somebody addicted to getting stem cells
they're crazy stories like what if these
Global Elites like these powerful
wealthy individuals who do these blood
transfusions just say like I'm gonna
give myself stem cells every other week
that way I can live forever like
wouldn't it replace all the damaged
cells forever and just keep you alive do
you remember the show Silicon Valley on
HBO and they had people doing the blood
transfers yeah it was a real real thing
yeah that's real they they they're these
guys that will hire like boys a 20 year
old dude and they say what they do is
they'll go to a gym and they'll find
guys who just want to work out they get
a drug test and they'll give me drug
test and they'll be like what's your
diet like and they'll say okay you
qualify we'll pay you 150 000 a year to
do a once a month blood transfusion and
they're like wow just once a month yup
and they get four guys and every week
they get young blood pumped into their
bodies which heals them do you remember
that billionaire who was like spending
all that money to make himself young yes
yes he's not even that rich he gets uh
stem cells he does that with his son and
then he does it for his dad and so
they're like so he gets his son stem
cells yeah oh wow yeah that's gotta be
like draining the life of your kid you
know uh I just watched this movie called
Paradise on Netflix I think it just came
out so I don't want to spoil it too much
but the premise is that they discover a
way to transfer effectively they
simplified as transferring time
so someone who's young can sell years
off their life to someone who's older
and it D ages them and ages them
people would do that though absolutely
so there's Brokers and they'll be like
look man you're 20 years old right you
don't need these three five years you'll
be you'll you'll be 25 you're still
young no one will even know you've aged
and we're gonna pay you 50 000 imagine
what you could do at 20 with 50 000 they
go to one guy and he says he wants this
18 year old kid to sell 15 years off his
life for 700 000 Euro because it's a
German movie and the kid's like I just
turned 18 I'll be 30. he's like yes but
with 700 000 Euro you can bring your
family into the country and start a
business and make a better life for your
family and then like it's the kid to
sign away 15 years of his life the
movie's pretty kind of like the movie
Click too in a weird way you know yeah
you're just like Adam Sandler yeah
trading success and just you know
skipping out in your life the
experiences think like the premise is
actually really interesting because
think about it what do you think about
this there's somebody who is uh
not a hard worker doesn't care about
life doesn't want to work
sitting in their living room playing
video games all day and they're you know
let's say they're 20 years old and
they're like I don't want to get a job I
don't want to do anything this is so
dumb and then there is a scientist who
is dedicated his life to cancer research
and he's made a bunch of breakthroughs
and he's like 80. would it be ethical to
tell that that 18 year old kid to sell
15 years to the 80 year old so the 80
year old can keep doing his research to
cure cancer or like yeah and that in
that circumstance it was all consensual
like the kids I don't even care give me
the money and then the 18 year olds now
effectively 32 but he gets paid a couple
hundred grand which funds his nonsense
life and then the scientist goes back to
work and gets 15 more years see I was
thinking like people who like don't want
to be alive anymore like you could sell
the remaining drug addicts until last
month right but then if you sell it you
leave money to whoever you want you get
everything I don't know man that's crazy
but this is a suicide too that's a
that's a weird psyop like where you're
basically getting people that are
healthy or I think they recommended it
for an ex-pare Olympian that couldn't
get up their stairs yeah they're like
have you considered dying yeah that was
Canada yeah well how to die in Oregon
have this like if you've seen the
documentary is really interesting and
they they were talking people who were
Pro assisted suicide but they had one
man who was like I you know live below a
poverty line and I can't I have lung
cancer and they told me that the surgery
is too expensive for you know State
Healthcare to pay for but they will
cover the cost of assisted suicide if I
want to go that route which is just
that's dark yeah but now imagine it came
out I mean what 2011 but now but now
Imagine This
so you're you're 40 years old and you're
like I'm depressed and they're like you
qualified for medical assistance and
dying but what we'll do is instead of
just ending your life we'll transfer
your remaining 40 years to this person
and then they transfer and then you're
like ah and then they the other person's
like I'm young and healthy again it's
like instead of donating your body to
science you donate your remaining years
yeah to science well something's going
on because you know in China if you're
like a wealthy businessman in China you
can like basically they'll like put you
in a van and say you need a kidney or
even like a heart they literally will
get you one and here in America and in
Canada we don't have that yet there's a
lot of wealthy people that are having
heart failure that need and complete
hard but you know what's the best way to
get a healthy heart somebody has a bad
hip that one there's no depressed you
don't kill themselves you know the crazy
story is that uh wealthy uh Muslims in
like Arabic Nations like princes and
businessmen will pay China to harvest
the organs yeah uighur Muslims for them
because they're like they need special
people go from America to China to do
that Tim they're supposedly people that
go from all over over to go to China
that I mean you have to be highly
connected obviously but that that's a
not just Saudi Arabians are doing that
that's a part of the movie It's called
Paradise where basically there are
people who operate these pop-up time
transfer clinics where they take
refugees and then basically force them
to save the time a wealthy businessman
walks out with his jacket like walks
into the machine and they de-age him
it's crazy that's the sound of Freedom
they they talked a lot about organ
transport or organ harvesting and and
trafficking also like it's a lot about
kids the sound of freedom but I think it
was Tim Ballard actually was just
telling us that it was a lot about organ
harvesting too like that the traffic
human trafficking movement is more than
just slave labor they want them Hearts
they want them livers yep I think we
need to enroll with stem cells in
Laboratories because I cannot stand the
thought of people getting cut open and
having their organ disease you guys want
to know the worst thing about all this
we sit here and we say oh man the future
is going to suck think about how scary
and awful all this stuff is going to be
and then when we're in our 70s there's
gonna be a bunch of kids who are doing
doing all of this being like shut up old
man you're crazy yeah yeah and we're
going to be like you're you shouldn't be
sewing your organs and they're like wow
just grow another one well we already do
this now because everybody here except
for Alx I mean I don't know Hannah but
dude we grew up when you had to call
somebody on the set on a phone you
didn't have a cell phone you had to call
the landline how old are you
27. so he probably remembers that a
little bit but I'm just saying it was
not that long ago because I'm yelling at
these kids that have a cell phone when
they're in like first grade you know you
don't realize and back in my day we
didn't have a cell phone yeah in Korea
they put the street lights on the ground
did you see that there's like on the
bumper on the corners there so there's
so many people are on the curb because
so many people are looking down at their
phones
now wow sorry to interrupt him
Innovative but we're not saying things
like like some people are saying cell
phones are bad that I get but I'm saying
like there's gonna be kids floating
around in like full body suits with
neural link plugs in their eyes are
going to be just like rolled in the back
of their head and we're going to be like
these dang kids you know they I can't
believe this we we fought so hard just
staying bored you think they'll be
borged up by the time we're 70. have you
seen uh
yes and then there's also that other
show on Apple I didn't watch it but it's
where you could split yourself in two so
you have your work self and your leisure
self
so what you do is it's like this program
I need to watch it some someone's on the
show was telling us about it where it's
like oh I've got to go to work now and
then you activate the device which makes
your leisure yourself go to sleep and
then there's like a subconscious version
that works and then you wake up when you
come to your back home and works done
and then like the premise of the show I
guess is that the work versions of
people are going insane like one one
woman keeps getting pregnant and then
zonking herself out and then waking up
nine months later when the baby's been
delivering she gets paid money for the
surrogacy and she just keeps doing it
that's apparently part of the show I
haven't seen it though what's that one
called I don't know or What's that show
someone someone's gonna be able to chat
it they'll they'll know what the name is
I think that's sad though I think so
often like yeah moving towards a culture
that's like separate yourselves and numb
yourself in one part of your life and
not in the other and I just think that
like you know it's easy to look back at
certain things in history and be like it
was so much better then and I think you
have to be careful about that because of
course there are all kinds of
Innovations I'm grateful for but I think
you know these Generations after us that
are even more plugged in than ever like
you know gen Z is the most online
generation we've ever had until gen
Alpha comes along I think they will
wonder you know why someone didn't set
some limitations at some point like were
they better for having pursued the
technology and been granted unlimited
access to the internet and I just think
ultimately no well Trump always says
make America great again and then I try
to think when was America great uh when
was the last time and I'll tell you it
was the 90s when Bill Clinton was
getting BJs in the Oval Office
basically because of that yeah well that
was a big part of it but ever since then
we've just been downhill the internet
SRP that was our Peak the you know late
night shows that's where everybody
watched we don't all you know go around
the TV Roseanne was hot and it was the
last decade
name a decade
I don't know 60s yeah
I know the 90s the 90s culturally is the
last decade so we we can always go go
back and be like oh man The Roaring 20s
oh the depression in the 30s World War
II in the 40s oh the 50s civil rights
60s you know they were in the 20s 70s
disco rock or whatever the 80s you can
you can imagine the way people dressed
you can imagine the music they listen to
by those decades the 90s we can remember
the flannels and the jeans and the and
now
what's 2000 yeah what is it what do you
think in the in the 2000s 80s and 90s
they're going to say the same thing
about nope no when they say the 20s will
be like the 1920s or the 2020s and this
is why instead of calling it gen Alpha I
want to call it Alpha gen and then we'll
go beta gen gamma gen so because by the
time we get back to Gen X it has to be
x-gen so otherwise you won't know which
at Gen X they're talking about the one
from you know the 16 26 Generations
about something else like yeah it's
called Alpha Genesis they all have
different names there's the greatest the
silent there's the Boomers Gen X the
Millennials gen Z gen Z just because of
Gen X yeah and there's Gen Y no one
really is that gen Alpha I think they're
gonna make up a different name for it
they're gonna call it like I don't know
the the neurogen or like the neural link
generation or something like dude we're
in the 20s or it's 20s again yeah
roaring 20. that's weird
yeah we got uh 10 more years until world
war three kicks off do you think what
are the what's the over under on World
War III for real bro uh in the next time
Modine told us 2025 yeah Modine said it
yeah and then and then I Googled it and
he was right you looked it up and I told
you the future well he was completely
correct look at this
Air Force General predicts war with
China in 2025 tells officers to prep by
firing a clip at a Target and aim for
the head I hope I am wrong but my gut
tells me we will fight in 2025 said
General Mike minahan in a memo sent to
the officers He commands and obtained by
NBC News well where's minahan now
what's he up to yo this was January I
believe this was seven months ago I
believe it with everything that's
breaking out in Africa right now that
with Ukraine and Taiwan you just get all
these huge huge like events popping up
all across the globe and you know what's
going on in Antarctica is where their
secret base is die in the Earth yeah
okay I know that the Earth is not a
spinning ball so don't say all the world
leaders have have conspired to build a
deep underground base and they do have
they're playing this war is a big game
and they've all agreed that when the
game ends they'll all go hang out in the
underground base and then whoever won
one under the Denver Airport no it's in
Antarctica yeah the Denver Airport
something's weirder that and then the
runways are shaped like a swastika type
in Denver Airport runway shaped like
swastika because it makes living lies
structurally worse yeah and you know
that horse killed at sculptor the person
that sculpted that it fell on him and
died whoa yeah Denver Airport horse also
they had another functional airport when
they built they call it Lucifer because
the blue there's a lot of like weird
paintings or whatever on the walls in
the like the basement it's got an
interesting energy it's so high up so I
imagine it's flood proof
maybe they can't get to Antarctica fast
enough we go to the Denver Airport and
this is where um go to that Norad is
right here in the mountains and in
Colorado Springs I was just over there
uh and then there's other Mountain bases
apparently
right there
oh look at that
that's crude what what effect yes
accurate I mean I guess they didn't need
if if they wanted runways they could
have done two runways on one and two
runways on the other and they didn't
make other airports
yeah it's highly funded they spent a
bunch of money on this airport and it's
not even you know Denver is not like a
great International Airport spot right I
mean
there's something weird going there it's
in the middle of the country and it's
high up and that's where they say all
the elites are going to go to when the
hits a fan well because NORAD was
there but I don't know we're really
close to mount weather and what's the
other one
uh Raven Rock yeah but that's
decommissioned now right so they say I
suppose Mountain no they did a big
Expansion Project didn't they on Raven
Rock Raven Rock expansion I still want
to go to gym Justice's uh Resort that
has the Declassified bunker in it where
they were like if there's nuclear
bombing we're going to send Congress
here you guys know about this no where's
that uh it's in West Virginia governor
Jim Justice's family owned I'm trying to
remember what it's the Greenbrier hotel
when you look up Raven Rock you just get
video games because it's in uh fallout
but yeah there was big news about uh the
expansion of Raven Rock Mountain Complex
I mean we do have dumbs deep underground
military bases right right and we're
super close because uh we're really
close to DC so I think Mount weather is
like what like a half mile half an hour
uh drives north of us I want to go
like The Story Goes if you pull up guys
with guns jump out and they tell you to
get the F out and turn around well Tim
you've had you've had exertus on here
who talks about tartaria that you know
we've had a mud
I
think there's probably something
underground in Dallas right outside of
Dallas there's a city called Rockwall
where there's just a huge wall
Underground
of rocks that it doesn't even make sense
no one knows why it's like it's from the
Neolithic era they have no idea in
Rockwall Texas there's just a huge you
know basically like a fortress dude I
guess 12 000 years ago that great North
American flood just annihilated the
North American continent wiped out all
the megafauna just smeared the the
surface so God knows what's underneath
it at some point I mean I don't know I'm
not a scientist journalist any of that
I'm an idiot just real quick correction
Mount weather is south of us not North
nice dude if there was ancient Advanced
culture in North America that got
smeared and covered by that flood
there's more and more evidence of maybe
not Advanced but like an advanced enough
culture like being in the North America
for thousands of years I mean there's
the serpent in Illinois or something
Urban Hill yes Ohio Ohio
Serpent Mound I'm not sure exactly how
big it is but on the equinox box the
summer equinox the head of the serpent
which is all made from Earth points
directly at the Sun and it's just like
it's you'd have to have a bird's eye
view to really be able to design
something like this so either that or it
shows how good oh yeah this thing right
here yeah I've been there yeah I visited
that when I was like 12. it's awesome
see if you can find other images because
you can only really see it from the sky
the story is that during the last
glacial period before the Melt uh that
the glaciers had come down south all the
way to Ohio and North America and they
got to the mouth of The Serpent Mound
and the glacier stopped and they felt
like it was some Spirit was protecting
them from the glaciers so they built I
think it was already a burial mound at
that point and then they then they
turned it into a serpent but in the
beginning it was just a some sort of
spiritual Mountain well there's ancient
pyramids somewhere I think maybe
Tennessee or something like that made
out of dirt so that proves aliens you're
saying aliens oh yeah yeah alien
compression they were already here and
they left
they're like we're done here well you
know that this is what they'll tell you
every single school kid when they go to
school they'll say that Christopher
Columbus discovered America yet when he
got here there was a bunch of Indians so
there are people here already yeah so
how did he discover a place where
there's already Indians or there already
a civilization Native Americans and
technically he landed in the Bahamas so
yeah Leif Erickson was here in like 880
is a viking the Vikings yeah but
Christopher Columbus 19 what is it 1842
so the scandalous 1642
see my whole childhood I feel like they
were in the process of walking that back
okay well he landed sort of here and
then also really
1492.
they've erased Columbus Day
that wasn't my experience when I was
growing up I went to school and they
said you know in 1492 Columbus sailed
the ocean blue and then when I came home
and told my mom she was like there were
already people here when I was like
you're older than me so what I'm saying
is like where they were teaching it to
you and by the time I got to school they
were like well probably not so much and
now the time that like my younger
sisters were significant this is this is
this is Viking Erasure well and
supposedly too you know when the
pilgrims came over they actually tried a
socialistic system and it failed
possibly really yeah what was that like
that because shared everything yeah
because they came here with limited
resources they tried allocating
everything in a centralized way and it
just didn't work wow they all died
everybody but most of them socialism had
failed dude Christopher Columbus the
star story of him and his brothers is
nuts and his brothers apparently were
just brutal Psychopaths and he gave them
free reign to just drag people around by
their hair like women down the street
and stuff and they're just beat it just
it was a different time a different
culture apparently Columbus had syphilis
was it just syphilis ridden psycho I
don't know it was a different maybe
maybe it's fake news and maybe he was a
beautiful human oh man look at a picture
Christopher Columbus he looks like the
devil like he looks beautiful picture of
Christopher Columbus what does that
means like this is the painting of of
evil right here this is the guy that
discovered America oh God he didn't
discover America they told us he did
he's the European it's that colored one
above that I was looking at this one
look at it I should be here if it wasn't
for Christmas it looks like the guy from
The Bear once that guy's name and misery
in those eyes look at those fingers it's
kind of weird
yeah the guys yeah his index finger is
really long and he just let his brothers
just also it's like a gang sign I don't
know what he's doing he's a West Side
for Life Christopher Columbus it is a
different time they were hard men they
sailed the ocean blue
but yeah I got no love for Christopher
Columbus I'm very happy to see Columbus
Day go well we're gonna go to super
chats everybody's having already but you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share this show with
your friends become a member at
timcast.com to support our work and you
can buy coffee at casper.com let's read
what you got all right where we at
what do we have Arrow says sorry Tim
only got 20 minutes into culture war and
had to give up too many Bros it's as bad
as the girls who you who use like and
guys who use f every second word well I
hear you uh modine's had a lot of really
funny things or some good conversation
but uh unfortunately sometimes just uh
these shows they they go too far and too
so episode just is is gone he said some
stuff that you know his Secrets yeah his
secrets we told them he told secrets and
said that you know he would be liable to
execution okay yeah he was he was
worried about a safety better removed uh
yeah it was a safety issue let's grab
some more Super chats
where we at
Bryn Terra Nova says Ian I'm listening
in from the ER today I brought some
crystals with me can you send me some
good vibes and healing energy thanks
yeah put your palm on the Crystal let it
touch like your inner Palm where the
soft tissue is and let it the heat from
the crystal go into you
if you stuck the crystal up your
butthole with that no it would probably
yeah talk to a doctor Barack Obama did
that actually
yeah
okay guys you know Dad did she really do
that to sell this Jade egg do you like
sticks her into your vagina that like is
supposed to help you heal and also maybe
with kegels or something yeah sorry okay
let's talk about cultures
says I've been doing the Andrew Tate
diet all week and I feel great I drink
coffee smoke cigars and do push-ups
until it feels like my blood is on fire
I work and train all day and fast until
dinner oh wild yeah I heard it uh Tate
say that he drank 15 cups of coffee a
day or something crazy
Raymond g stanbert JR says shout out to
pbd for doing uh for doing and Vivek
doing a town hall gonna have to swing
back and finish it after tonight's show
of course Valor Victory Vivek 2024. VR
his initials are by the way Vegas is
just like every video I see from him
he's like nailing it no he is really
good he's running the campaign that
DeSantis should have run yeah yeah
because he really is he's he's defending
Trump while I I don't know how to
explain it why DeSantis just totally
went after Trump when Trump helped him
out so much I don't understand why that
would he would think that would be a
winning strategy because they went after
him yeah I know but you'd still like you
you look good if you were the good cop
like if you were the nice guy even if
they're still going after you and you're
saying nice stuff it makes him look
better yep you know instead of fighting
fire with fire
the first thing was when Trump's
indictment and he said look I don't know
what goes into paying off uh porn stars
yeah instead of instead of coming out
boldly and being like you will not lay a
finger on Donald Trump in my state have
a nice day and walking away that's what
he should have done yeah
I mean he's got bad advisors he's got
bad bad advisors it's unfortunate
but I'm thinking like any moment now
we're gonna see ramaswamy polling in
second oh yeah and they know it they
know it more and more stories are coming
about donors being like nah not until
you improve this yeah pausing the
DeSantis donors yeah
what do we got DeSanto law plc's pllc
says Tim how have you not mentioned how
obnoxious the Women's U.S USA soccer
team is take a poll how many Americans
are cheering against them go Sweden you
know I was insufferable and overrated
this is a brilliant thing because Lionel
Messi just signed with Miami right and
it's going super viral they're playing
in Dallas and every single ticket sold
out at the uh um Stadium it's like 112
000 uh person Stadium it's one of the
biggest and the women's soccer team
supposed to be really frustrated because
this is their time where they get all
the you know publicity and instead
Lionel Messi's getting all of it so
nobody's even talking about like women
that's true every year though we never
talk about women's soccer it's every
four years right no but like I hear in
the press that Messi is a very good dude
like he's a he's like a general
genuinely good guy the fans love him
he's really talented and then when you
look at the women's team they're just
like represented by very snooty and mean
people yeah Megan rapinos right she's
like the one who's on the float
screaming I deserve this well she said
that yeah yeah this is like after
one of the viral videos I remember of
her with her purple hair screaming I
deserve it I remember them verify this
for me Twitter correct she deserves
everything yeah you know the women
played a bunch of 11 year olds and lost
14. whatever 14 and under is 14 under I
think there was 11 year old it was a
freshman High School soccer team yeah
whatever they lost and didn't they say
that they were playing light on the boys
because they just wanted to be nice
you give me a break I mean the
controversy too now is because they've
been so good historically over the last
three World Cups and they tied what I
can't remember what country it was and
they're celebrating like they just won
the actual championship and they tied
almost got knocked out of the tournament
and so like you have this new group of
girls on the team that are just like not
that competitive USA Women's soccer is
like the best women's soccer anywhere
and that's changed all this year so we
have this very important one from
nonpartisan kitty saying where is the
CEO Mr belkus he's actually sleeping
underneath the Papasan nice and and it's
good because I was worried he was gonna
piss on the floor and so we made a deal
with Alex that we would allow him to be
here so long as Alex cleaned up the piss
if he pissed and I would do it gladly
because I love cats I'm suffer from
toxoplasmosis a parasite oh actually
it's in my brain if you move your chair
a little bit like this another way other
way
you can see Mr bocus oh a little bit you
can see him he's sleeping underneath the
Papasan he found a good spot and he just
he likes the vibration he likes to be in
the room where where we are he just
likes to come in the room where we are
at and then sleep and like he's so so
well that's what my cats do when I
podcast they all go to my podcast Studio
I mean at least you can feel the energy
though I think is what it is it's like
being raised someone might be lonely you
know I mean when we were we were having
sushi after the morning show and bocus
came down and jumped up on the window so
just laid in the Sun and just killed for
three hours oh it's awesome yeah dude
life is good huh little dude he's
chilling well do you ever feel kind of
like this sounds crazy because I
basically like animals more than humans
but I'm sometimes and this is gonna
sound crazy I'm kind of jealous of my
dog sometimes because they don't have to
worry about anything they have no stress
they just get to be fed by me all day
they're only stresses when you're out of
town yeah exactly right my animals are
stressed right now because I'm gone but
that's the thing like you're the center
of your they stress about you constantly
yeah I guess that is a good point your
uh Pit Bull Ginger yeah beautiful dog
she's great what an amazing
it's sad I look at my dog I'm like I'm
kind of jealous of you you just get to
live this great life but I mean
obviously I want to be a human I don't
want to be a dog but it is kind of nice
not having stress and responsibility
think about it like a dog can walk into
the middle room full of people and
everyone just says they love you and
they're all giving you massages it's
like life is good that's what they say a
dog's life right
all right here we go five against eight
says Tim your Newsome prediction reminds
me of Angels and Demons
the camera lengo plants the antimatter
so we can swoop in and save everyone
swaying the conclave to pick him as the
new pope
okay not familiar with I know Angels and
Demons it was like what was that the pre
before Da Vinci Code or something yeah I
think so
yeah I remember The Da Vinci Code was a
big deal
yeah with Tom Hanks it was a ghost came
out the first one was pretty good
all right let's grab some more what do
we have what is this where are we at
Cain Abel says Tim Buchanan was not the
second worst president he was the third
Truman was the second and Biden was the
first Scandal Truman
what do you guys think about Harry
Truman I don't know he launched the atom
bomb uh obviously he's the one that
ended World War II but he had to make a
calculated risk are we going to send
Americans into Japan under the mainland
and have him are you throwing up on
machines I'm pro-nuclear bomb on Japan
you are yeah because they would have
probably hundreds of thousands of
Americans would have died in that Siege
on that island did you know or this they
say this that they had prior knowledge
before Pearl Harbor that they were gonna
oh that was Roosevelt but they may have
they knew that I've heard that they knew
the Japanese were coming they didn't
know where exactly and also it's very
convenient to be attacked if you want to
send your country to war but I don't
know they needed it they needed support
yeah they had to have Pearl Harbor day
there was a strong anti-war sentiment
because they were like dude on the other
side of the planet why do we care why
are we gonna die for what's happening in
Europe again World War one was bad
enough okay well that's a good point so
I would say most conservatives are
against the war in Ukraine what would
happen What would have to happen in your
opinion Tim to make the people on the
right be impossible it would be
literally literally well okay not
literally but here's what I think right
now anything that happens will not be
the fault of the war but of Joe Biden
the Democrats and the establishment and
based on how things are going certainly
something could happen where like
Vladimir Putin kidnaps a busload of
Orphans and then goes on camera and goes
starts hurting children but that's not
reality reality is is a conflict over a
region and if it escalates to say like
nuclear artillery the reaction in the
United States will be against Biden not
Putin they're going to be like you
exacerbated this you sent the money you
guys were doing this and this did not
need to happen if the U.S did not get
involved in Ukraine Putin would have
walked to the Don bass and it would have
been done
so they I'm not saying that's all true
I'm saying they will they will claim
that they will blame the establishment
the Democrats etc for escalating the war
and causing the escalation see I think
people are so dumb if they did drop a
nuclear weapon on a Kiev I think
conservatives be like well it is time to
get in there and put a boot in their ass
Toby Keith style you know you hope your
Rio cons would but yeah the Trump people
yeah the Trump people would be like if
Trump was President this never would
have happened
yep I think there's some yeah truth to
that and then even if even if so if if
icbms go flying and cities be blowing up
like okay gloves are off I have no idea
but if Putin uses like a a nuclear
artillery like these are smaller yield
stuff 100 kilotons and you know
strategic targets military targets I
think the reaction would be
Donald Donald Trump's statement would be
like this war will end overnight with
diplomacy the moment you elect me and is
approval Skyrocket and Joe Biden will go
the pro-war route saying it's time for
intervention and that will cause Biden
to drop to three percent or something in
in approval rating yep I for a long time
I was like just we got to see the
Eastern Dawn bass to the Russians they
want that trade port and Sebastopol
there's no stopping them short of like
total Annihilation like they just we
have Libya we have Iraq give them the
trade Port but now I'm like well if they
take the trade port and they they uh
fortify the the Crimea then what's what
will turkey do if Turkey leaves NATO and
joins the Russians then what do we do
and like it's like Hitler like they gave
Hitler a little bit the what was his
name Neville Chamberlain he gave him a
little bit with the Sudan land and then
they're like now that all appease him
and then he just wouldn't stop after
that so like I think people are afraid
Putin won't stop after he gets the dawn
back but I don't think turkey's as
concerned about it I don't think so at
all he's just gonna have to learn Trade
Practices the Russians and the Turks are
going to have to work together to get
those shipments because it's going to be
massive amounts of trade coming out of
the Black Sea by the Russians so if
Russia took over the world what they got
rid of uh pride parade and stuff do you
think servers would like it they're
probably like yeah let's we should
welcome there are a lot of people on the
right who are saying that Putin is
fighting against the demons and the
devils and stuff like that it's like
it's not true dude Putin is another
interest who's trying to secure power
it's it's you to truly understand their
motivations and know what they know is
very is impossible but there's no good
there's no there's no good guys yeah
well Brittany Greiner I went viral
because I asked her if uh you know
um but it's funny because she didn't
stand for the national anthem yet in
Russia they don't even have a pride
parade yet she can come to America and
celebrate you know it's just funny not
having any sort of love for your own
country when you even go to a foreign
country you think she would come back to
me like this is the greatest place on
Earth I love America but instead she's
like all right I will stand for the
anthem and now she's taking a mental
health break all right let's read some
more Michael beacon says please stop
being conspiracy theorists the aliens
are real and they really want us to
trust the government and forgive them
for their crimes like that one dude said
nothing suspicious at all
okay that was something funny someone
super chatted us and they said that uh
the conspiracy theory is gonna be that
aliens aren't real because not the
government said they're real there's
gonna be like no way there's no way
that's me I've already said it
they're right I mean there's something
weird I I think it's more likely if
there are some sort of interdimensional
beings they're like demons from hell or
from heaven or something I don't think
it's necessarily A Space Alien from uh
that 10 000 light years away on a ship I
just don't I wonder why the 10 000 light
your way aliens would want to come here
yeah we'd go there
but like research
yeah sure but they want to come here
would they be interested enough I mean
think about it this way you're an alien
10 million light years away you've
discovered Intergalactic travel you can
travel speed of light and then you find
out you are not
you are not going to heaven you have the
wrong beliefs wouldn't you want to seek
out those who actually you're talking
about Evangelical aliens right now I'm
saying the aliens no not heaven but
they're not allowed to get in so they're
going to come join they come to Earth
for Scientology and then what happens is
they find all these people being like
the Son of God came to Earth and then
they're like yo we live on Zig abort and
he never came to us like we're in
trouble we better figure it so now
they're converting and they're bringing
the religion back to their home planet
but it's like a new version because you
know Jesus didn't say he was going to
send them to Heaven aliens aren't going
to heaven right
I'm presenting missionaries to wherever
aliens came to Earth because they want
salvation
I don't that I have a hard time with it
man I'm always trying to be here L Ron
Hubbard zone right now yeah it's
something about scientology
space aliens
do you believe that Jesus is the son of
God I mean yeah I guess I was sometimes
so so what would an alien be thinking if
he finds out that Earth is the only path
of salvation
thank you for sending all the aliens to
Heaven
yeah you gotta do it somehow otherwise
what do you do as long as they'll tie
the jokes he'll take their money
let's grab some more we got yoshiaki
Koga says Ian it was Korea a Korean who
published the paper on the room
temperature thank you a Chinese
researcher first to confirm some of the
findings got it awesome
I don't know if I believe it though yeah
I'm still the jury's out man Jeremy riss
is working diligently to reproduce it
right now as we speak you can follow him
on Twitter alien scientist Ray from Palm
Bay says my friend Kyle is getting
married tomorrow can you say something
to Kyle and Emily don't do it
I'll definitely do it
do it is um a business proposal and you
can make a lot of money working together
as a team so do it you can also lose a
lot of money in a divorce so get a
prenup prenups are good idea I think
they should be built into marriage
anyway
you guys are really missing the energy
this guy was hoping for oh I know he's
creative your love will stand the test
of time the business contract's a
secondary part of it she's probably
cheating on you so Mr Bogus just jumped
up on the table because he just wants to
hang out with us
he's actually and he's also standing by
the rib eye carnivore snack because he
knows there's beef in there and he wants
to eat it but he can't because he'll die
oh bye Alex he's obsessed with Alex
don't eat this it's too small she wants
the ghost pepper one he goes right for
the ghost pepper one look at it he's
trying to get it balls he does he's
trying to eat the ghost the Scorpion
Reaper pepper one don't this is
dangerous pepper one look at bucko yeah
Alex said he was too scared to eat it he
says it's beef he wants to rub his hand
no because I'm a vegetarian and this
goes against my church of Scientology
religion you realize it when you scratch
his jaw well that's tall video Master
40K says can you shout out my favorite
artist Divide music he just released a
new song Today focused on Batman very
cool congratulations am I the only
person that likes it that lizzo made all
of her uh backup dancers eat bananas out
of other people's vaginas I'm open to
the to liking it that's good didn't Tim
make you eat a banana out of a woman's
vagina yeah
inappropriate when the cameras go off it
gets crazy around here no actually uh
Ian's Ian's hazing ritual is he makes
everyone perform Shakespeare in front of
all the other employees Barefoot
Barefoot he doth protests too much yeah
you got to memorize the whole body it's
like well I don't know you know Ian said
tomorrow and tomorrow actually he makes
everything he makes all the new
employees watch him do him like this Ian
what about the Shakespeare conspiracy
that he didn't even write I think that
might be real I know actually a wealthy
businessman or a duke or something but
he would have been because they would
talk about the queen that they
would have been killed or they was like
would have been bad for their career I
mean one of the theories is that it was
a whole team of people yeah because it
was like so much good art pumped out by
apparently some random guy yeah west of
Our Generation right is he known for
producing a ton of Art and like people
are amazed by that that's the people
want to believe that he's a real guy
because he's so inspirational to think a
guy could do all that and act they can
dude that's why we know their names Bill
shakes you ever play Civilization well I
was just in London
he's trying to sleep on your head but I
thought that's so weird that Shakespeare
is supposedly rebuilt the Globe Theater
by slowly stealing parts from the
original Globe Theater did you know that
no it burned the first one burned down
yeah and then but something happened and
they were taking he would like secretly
take parts from that Globe to build the
New Globe Theater interesting that's
never heard the story yeah Google is
like Theater history
with parts of the original Globe Theater
I tend to believe that he was a real guy
I don't know why I studied a lot of
Shakespeare maybe that's why yeah I feel
like I think because I studied it I feel
like he's one person but it would make
so much sense if it was like the Disney
like a corporation of the time was just
churning out and used the guys I
mean you know I feel like he must have
written the majority of himself I can't
say that no one ever was like oh maybe
you should change it like surely he had
an editor right it's certainly someone
at some point read through and I was
like I think it'd be funnier this way if
you tell Chad gbt to write in
Shakespearean language will it right
yeah oh yeah iambic pentameter yeah
I think it's like seven what is that
somehow look it up
all right we'll grab some more
the one game that one gamer says I heard
Tim talking about the mob earlier today
and I think he'd like talking to Michael
Fran francise Francis oh yeah former
captain in the Colombo crime family and
author of the book Mafia democracy
that'd be cool that was good I was
basically saying after seeing what's
going on in like New York and stuff
especially today maybe we need the mafia
and and what I mean is I was I watched
that clip from A Bronx Tale
where it's such a good scene in so many
ways
have you guys seen the movie I've not
seen the movie I just saw the clip I
need to watch the whole movie but
basically what happens is my boss is
talking and also there's a commotion
they hear it he goes outside and he sees
a bunch of like bikes motorcycles goes
into a bar and there's like arguing he's
like what's the problem and the
bartender is like you guys he's trying
to eat it
bartender is like these guys aren't
dressed properly to be in this bar and
then the the biker leader guy looks at
the mob boss and goes look man we just
want to have one beer we'll hang out
we'll drink we'll be on our way and then
he goes spoken like a gentleman serve
him their beers and then the bartender
gives the beers to the bikers who
immediately shake them up and spray the
bartender down while laughing then the
mob boss goes okay now you're being
impolite you need to leave and then the
biker leader turns around and he goes Fu
we're not going anywhere so the mob boss
walks over the door closes it locks it
walks back and goes now you just can't
leave and then the bikers look around
like huh and then the door busts open
and a bunch of good old boys come in
with baseball bats are beating the crap
out of the bikers and then they throw
them out but the reason I say it's a
good scene is
the mafia guy these guys broke the rules
they weren't dressed properly
but they politely asked and he obliged
them he said spoken like a gentleman let
him have their beers like hey I'm an
honorable guy you're you're a nice fella
I'm not gonna hold it against that
you're not dressed right but then those
guys disrespected him and attacked the
bartender and then he all he did was ask
him to leave he didn't say you you
sprayed the bar to not how dare you he
said okay guys time to go and they still
said no way we're doing whatever we want
and then he's like okay so what would
happen if people in this neighborhoods
knew that they were guys of Honor that
would be polite to you and treat you
well so long as you treated other people
well but if you cross the line they
there would be in a cultural enforcement
you wouldn't be seeing these robberies
you wouldn't be seeing these riots these
teen takeovers because there'd be
someone to look up to and respect
granted I'm not literally saying
organized crime because there's bad
stuff they do they're shootouts I'm just
saying yeah the culture of like the guys
in the neighborhood being like look
we're gonna be nice to you we're going
to treat you with respect even if you're
not dressed right as long as you're a
good person but if you screw with us we
protect our neighborhood we don't have
that anymore after my parents emigrated
and they basically were living in New
York in the 80s uh and they went to buy
property and they were looking in
Brooklyn because that's what they could
afford and their realtor took them
around and was like yeah yeah one of the
good things about this neighborhood is
it's controlled by the mob so there's no
cry no that's a real thing la casa no
show the mafia they have Unwritten rules
where you cannot kill a child even if
you're you know you hate this person you
want them dead so they have rules where
they won't kill a child yet we drop
drone strikes on children all the time
so you could argue that the mafia has
more of a moral compass in the United
States government depends on the mafia I
guess Koza Nostra is the name of that
one that's La Casa Nostra is the name
for the mafia that's that's bogus is
using Alex's baseball cap is a bed and
it's not working very well he put his
whole all four of his feet on it before
yeah
he got all of his feet the big downside
with me with or having like because I'm
big on enforcement of Law and it's
really disturbing to watch crowds form
and mobs and Destroy and like where
there's the National Guard where the
police where's the enforcement where's
the protection but like the mob doesn't
have like a code of ethics I mean maybe
they do it's Word of Mouth like if you
insult the mob boss I think it's written
down because you do a ceremony when you
get into the family I guess I should say
they don't have a constitution and Free
Speech yeah so if you talk crap about
the mob boss good luck it's like in the
mob you're not allowed to be gay Vito
spedophora and The Sopranos they found
out he's gay and they kill him but
there's like exceptions if you go to
prison you can supposedly be gay if
you're locked up
that makes um that's understandable so
there are rules to their weird game that
they play all right let's read some more
we got Ryan the eating Warrior says
Ukraine re-arrests blogger that was
tortured before he could get into
Hungary seeking Asylum the U.S was 100
behind this that's coach red pill and I
heard they caught him I heard he was
capturing he was captured I kind of like
coach red pill he's funny I mean uh so
there was a video that went out where
they said you may have heard about the
man who was trying to flee you know that
was a transgender uh Ukrainian military
officer oh was it yeah the person was
trying I don't know I don't that's uh
whatever I'm more concerned about Coach
Red Bull being captured again and
tortured and yeah
whatever but I also wonder why it is
he's like I'm gonna go straight to the
Border I'm like and he tweeted it a 25
tweet Thread about it right what and
then like yes why wouldn't you like
just hand your phone to a friend and
tell them to start doing normal things
then ride your bike through the woods
yeah that was crossed my mind he widely
tweeted out yeah I thought that was
weird you bought it he brought his phone
with him they're like tracking you dude
yeah or just tweet after you cross the
border I mean why would you tell on
yourself like that but I don't know
right he told himself and they tracked
him down and uh these people are evil
and they can triangulate where wherever
we are with our cell phones yeah I got a
story from Venezuela uh I was in
Venezuela and uh I got accused of being
a spy because some Occupy Wall Street
dude tweeted to events to Venezuelan
Glenn back is what I call him because it
was like a similar story like he was a
TV host and he did a web thing and but
he was leftist and they said hey this
guy's in your country doing this stuff
so this guy went on his show and said
hey find this guy Tim Poole look at what
he does and they accuse me of being a
CIA agent so I had to flee the country
like I'm taking I'm at my hotel in uh
Caracas and I get out of the shower and
I look at my Twitter it's like you have
12 000 mentions and I was like what and
then I hit like the like the open and
also it's like we're gonna kill you
we're coming for you we'll find you all
because they thought you were a CIA
plant oh yeah yeah it's Venezuela dude
and so uh I leave the country
and uh I come back to the U.S
and I thought it was really really funny
because like I'm here in Brooklyn at the
time I was in Brooklyn and so I tweeted
enjoying Empanada or arepas in in
Caracas or whatever so that they would
still think I was there because you're a
troll and then what happened is the next
day I get a message from a friend of
mine I had spoken to in years and he
says bro the FBI just started asking me
questions about you what's going on and
I'm like what so I call him he doesn't
answer I call him he doesn't answer I
call him he doesn't answer
so I was like okay he's not answering
two or three hours later he calls me
back I answer and he's like yo what's up
and I was like you message me what's
going on the FBI and he goes what and
I'm like you message me on Facebook
what's some FBI called you and he goes
what the are you talking about and
I was like bro you messaged me on
Facebook he goes dude I haven't talked
to you in like four years and then I'm
like bro so I took a picture of the
message said it to him and he goes dude
I did not message you on Facebook and I
was like oh sure so I talked I hit up my
hacker Buddies
and I'm like I'm like yo yo some kind of
attack uh like an injection like someone
hacked his account and they said they
think it was
um API injection or something where
Venezuelan government hackers
went to my Facebook account saw who my
friends were chose someone and then
injected a message from him to me they
wanted me to call him so that my phone
would ping their Tower and they could
triangulate my position but I was in
Brooklyn so I was gone that's nuts that
is wild yeah and then I printed out the
message and then like when I was at Vice
I had a bunch of stuff on my wall I had
like fragments of of Lenin from the from
from Ukraine that like shattered and
then there were like little rocks on the
ground and I took some they sold his
hand they sold his head that was crazy
and then I had this message from this
fake you know I had a bunch of other
stuff I still have a bunch of the stuff
today I've like I have um I have police
tape from where that black supremacist
executed those two cops in Brooklyn
because that was my street and so the
next day when they cleaned everything up
the police tape was still on all the
light poles and just blowing in the
wings they ripped it so I walked up and
ripped a piece off and I I kept it I got
a bunch of stuff like that from all the
crazy stories I've covered no it's crazy
days serial killers do the same thing
Tim
they take a Memento from the tragedy so
maybe were you the real shooter did you
frame that man Tim this is the best
picture of bucko
he's fully I heard his name what a
beautiful cat all right
all righty would you kindly smash that
like button subscribe to the channel
share the show with your friends become
a member at timcast.com to support our
work directly and buy our coffee at
castbrew.com I'm not kid man I I ca I go
back and forth between rise with Roberto
Jr and Appalachia Knights being the best
Appalachian nights is dark so it's like
earthy and chocolatey and then Roberto
Jr is bright and light and they're just
it's it's so insanely good well Tim can
I give you one piece of advice if you do
want to have a successful Beverage
Company you have to do a Coca-Cola
didn't you have to put cocaine in your
first batch we can't do that but what if
we made an Alex steinblend okay well and
then we'll cut we'll cut you the problem
okay perfect portion of the processor
it'll be like your signature Prime Time
blend it's the cocaine in the Ukraine
yeah insane in the Ukraine blend coach
red pill is drinking it right now you
can follow the show at Tim cast IRL you
can follow me at timcast Alx you want to
shout anything out yep x.com
Alx follow me there right on Alex Prime
Time with Alex Stein on YouTube go give
that a subscription if you guys uh are
so kind thank you thank you
come up I'm ready for mcast.com follow
at timcast news on Twitter and Instagram
it's the best I just can't stand the X
thing if you want to follow me on that
website I'm at HC brimlow and I'm on
Instagram at handclear Duppy thank you
guys so much Ian Crossland follow me
anywhere guys I love great conversation
tonight I could do these all the time
more alien talk more weird stuff right I
was fun yeah Fridays are good rock and
roll we got bocus sleeping on your head
Mr bocus I posted a picture on Instagram
if you want to see yes instagram.comcast
you can look at the picture uh you guys
can follow me at Kellen PDL I'm pushing
the buttons over here
um and NFL is officially back as of
yesterday so go Steelers
that'll be fun
yeah we did a Super Bowl party this year
I'm looking for I love Super Bowl
parties do you gamble on sports videos
not really I I last year I gambled on
the coin toss and the color of the
Gatorade did you win any of them yeah I
did I wanna I wanna I think I want them
both oh yeah it was really good I can't
remember what I bought them I think
about 100 bucks that was on the coin
toss and I was like I don't even know
what this means I don't even know if
that's heads or Toes that and I walked
up and like you wanna all right yeah who
do you guys think's gonna win the Super
Bowl this year got any yes football team
yep
I love the Dallas Cowboys I'm from
Dallas but not the Dallas Cowboys too
early yeah well probably Cleveland Brown
we'll see we'll see all right everybody
thanks for hanging out it's a lovely
Friday and we will be back Monday and
we'll have Clips throughout the weekend
and we'll see y'all then